we have an investigation happening in
buffalo apparently before this tragic
incident occurred at the grocery store
advance warning was given to several
people one of which was a retired
federal agent so now it is being
reported by the buffalo news that there
is an active investigation into whether
or not this individual should be charged
as an accomplice
of course this story is going around
because a lot of people are looking into
let's just call it uh
nefarious and malicious means behind the
scenes involving federal agents with uh
these these uh
tragic incidents that have occurred i i
don't i don't believe
you know i don't blindly just believe
the theories that people are putting out
the conspiracies but i do think they're
they're it's interesting to talk about
because some people seem to think there
may be more going on and i think the
information we get out of these warrants
and investigation so guess what they're
investigating this guy
now typically when people investigate
themselves they don't find anything
wrong so who knows but there are a lot
of other questions about what happened
with the uvalde shooting like how this
poor kid
a couple days after his 18th birthday
was able to get a credit line or able to
get money to buy an extremely expensive
rifle get it delivered and pick it up
all in the span of less than two days
some people just
they want to know there needs to be an
investigation here but we have more
information coming out and i'm shocked
to say for the first time in a long time
the left and the right are united
they're united in their disdain for the
police
who stood in the hallway
as they heard the shots going off and
did nothing and outside barred parents
from getting in armed parents from
saving their kids so it's remarkable to
see
left-wing activists just as outraged and
for the same reasons as the writers so
hey who thought this would be the thing
that would unify us but when kids lose
their lives and police do nothing and
bar people from saving them i think
you're gonna get a lot of a lot of
people are gonna be angry so we're gonna
talk all about this and a bunch of other
stuff joining us to discuss this is
brian dean wright
good sir pleasure do you who are you yes
i am uh here to enjoy you all but uh
beyond being here i host a podcast
called the president's daily brief we
talk about a lot of international
affairs some domestic stuff but the
focus is just like the actual
president's daily brief which is a top
secret summary that's given to the
president every morning i do the same
thing with folks uh what's happening
around the world and we focus a lot on
why you should care because lots of
things around the world happen but
really why would i care if i'm in des
moines this morning right so we talk
about that and we talk about uh
solutions so how do we solve the
country's problems the world's problems
so that's what i do every morning at six
a.m and uh having worked at the cia
that's the uh the the reason i started
doing this pcb podcast your former date
state yes yeah well maybe currently can
you ever shake it oh let's talk about
that oh yeah all right but you did work
at the cia i did we'll definitely talk
about that in the deep state or whatever
else we have down turner as well yeah
and if there's a fed to my right my name
is jack
i have yes daniel turner power the
future uh great to be here again always
good to be with you and i was talking to
brian in the the green room i've
followed him for for years and years and
so it's actually really cool to meet you
in person so i'd like to be here uh ian
crossland what's up everybody i'm going
to do something a little controversial
and spin the ufo with my fingers
look at that look at that wobbly spin i
didn't say i was going to spin it fast
just said i was going to spin it and i
followed through
the chat has exploded everyone's saying
fed
oh yeah we talk about like a um a road
to was a road to redemption so is there
something like that when you're no
longer a fed or how long until you're
longer well you guys tell me what's the
penance like what's what's the the thing
that i have to do to make myself
redeemed in your talk show 100 bucks
right right just right right now
actually yeah yeah yeah yeah your soul
will be saved
what about you lydia i am also here in
the corner and i'm about to troubleshoot
a little audio buzz we seem to be having
i think i know what it is so hopefully i
can fix it but until then i'll start tim
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com become a member to
help support our work as a member you'll
get access to exclusive members only
segments from this show monday through
thursday at 11 pm you'll also be
supporting all of our journalists we're
probably gonna be hiring a bunch more
yo it's just really hard to hire
journalists right now because all the
good ones have jobs already because
they're good and they get paid well for
it i suppose if you look to the
corporate press you're going to not want
to hire those people so you know
the pool isn't that big but we're
working on it and uh you will also be
supporting our infrastructure we use
rubble rumble cloud services of course
because we are actively doing everything
we can to separate from the
establishment big tech machine which
also means thanks to our amazing
engineer and andy our cto if you go to
the home page of timcast.com these
streams are now there with the chat and
everything so cool so if you're logged
into youtube on the same browser you can
actually watch on timecast.com it's all
it all just takes time we're working on
it but with your support
we will get that job done and we've got
some more announcements coming soon and
i also just want to point out
so we're going to be doing culture
jamming is marketing and right now there
is a 70-foot picture of my face on top
of the abc news building i was talking
to so we got a billboard in times square
right on top of the good morning america
building and i was talking to carl
benjamin of the lotus eaters podcast he
was like congratulations man but you
know how do you track the impact of that
and i was like you don't but that's not
why i got it i got it so that there'd be
a 70-foot picture of my face on top of
the abc news building so every time
these people are coming to and from work
they can see that i am above them
i don't know if i don't know if they'll
actually care about that but it's a
statement about us
starting to move into these culturally
uh establishment spaces and uh you know
kash patel was talking about how they
did something similar the daily wire did
something similar so i don't know if
times square is really about good
marketing so we're actually planning
good marketing
but we've got it's a little vanilla but
we do have some pretty good culture
jamming as marketing events planned for
the next few months and we're talking
some of the greatest trolls in the
planet
and with your support we are going to uh
generate some press
so don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel right
now share the show with your friends it
is a lovely friday night let's read this
first story from the buffalo news
authorities investigating if retired
federal agent knew of buffalo mass
shooting plans in advance
they're actually wondering
if this dude should be charged as an
accomplice what they're basically saying
is that
in this dis i think was in the discord
that uh the oh i'm swallowing a run the
uh here we go
the the perpetrator shared the
information with six individuals one of
which was a retired uh federal agent
they say agents from the fbi are in the
process of tracking down and
interviewing the six people including
the retired agent and attempting to
determine if if any of them should be
charged as accomplices the two sources
with close knowledge of the probe told
the buffalo news the two sources did not
identify the agent by name and could not
confirm what agency he worked for
i got i just got to start off by saying
sometimes there are racist former
federal agents
sometimes people who are criminals work
for different departments or maybe this
guy was in a discord and did not see any
of this information and that's why he
didn't report it we don't know but the
reason i want to lead with this is
because there's a lot of questions
around all of these it's becoming
particularly prominent to see on twitter
and other platforms where people are
questioning how these things can
actually happen like how is it you know
with euvaldi a guy
two days after his 18th birthday it gets
one of the best most expensive rifles
possible what was his training how could
he have afforded it he was being made
fun of for being uh uh you know poor now
all of a sudden
you know so people question this stuff i
think there are simple solutions simple
answers to a lot of these things but i
do think
we could not debunk that truly and
honestly we can cast doubt onto these
theories but i think it's interesting so
i don't know what do you guys think
about this the uh the the potential
federal agent i should ask you brian as
as you are a former former former fed
maybe current
you just like current fed
yeah got it all right
yeah look there are uh there are bad
apples in every bunch aren't there and
whether this guy was knowledgeable and
actually
ignored his own training which is these
folks especially bureau guys they know
absolutely the signs the flags and when
and where to report those so he he
should have a very special sensitive
trip wires at the point and the fact
that he didn't do what he should have is
really odd and frankly disconcerting
because it it doesn't make sense
interesting some people were so i can't
confirm a lot of what people are posting
in these stories but some people are
saying that apparently these guys might
have been in uvaldi and buffalo in the
same discords or that the people egging
them on may have been in the same same
discords
i don't know if you go back all the way
to columbine
and you look at uh the investigation
into that
even even uh
dylan clayblot i think his name was i
forget
thank you but even
his family said you know he spent a lot
of time in the garage we always heard
these loud noises he was always blowing
things up um this is kind of similar in
the sense that there are a lot of
warning signs right like clearly he's
telling people just like the guy in
texas you know told people he told that
girl who he tagged on social media in
l.a like i'm gonna do this um i mean if
that isn't a sign that there is some
clear mental problem that there's this
very blatant cry for help there's
there's almost the desire to attract
attention
before the fact and i think right now
the conversation as it should be is you
know what else can we do but i think
what we're starting to see now is well
actually
there really isn't a need necessarily
for more laws or more sort of
bureaucratic steps it's just actually to
execute what the things that we were
supposed to do more thoughtfully more
consistently whether it's at the schools
uh you know making sure doors are shut
for pete's sake if you're a parent or
you're a loved one or you're a neighbor
and you start seeing this stuff
raise the flag do the things that we all
know to that work right so i don't know
in this case as we learn more that we
really should have an additional layer
of laws or whatnot it's really just
making sure that we what we do and you
know have on the books just execute that
more thoughtfully more consistently yeah
and i'll tell you this issue of training
that's one that i think is really odd on
this with this fellow because he was so
young there is no
he just got this gun that it's not a
light weapon to work with so some degree
of training exposure where did he get
that that's one of the things that i
have been looking at and looking for
yeah so uh
when someone when people are pointing
out this gun with taxes and shipping and
everything was too grand
you know a lot of people said how could
a guy who works at wendy's and is under
18 afford that because you'd have to uh
i mean
save up for how long i mean i suppose if
he's living this mom he's not paying
anything but then apparently he got to a
fight with his grandma or something over
a phone bill so he i mean maybe he
really just saved up this money and then
it's it actually is it could be quite
simple a credit card
you turn 18 you get a credit card if
you've got no bad credit you might get a
couple grand on a credit card yeah but
that's the time frame
so i'm not sure if this is correct i
don't know if you guys know you guys can
fact check me but it was it was two days
after his 18th birthday
can i so he ordered the gun online
and then maybe a week in advance it got
shipped in then he went there and picked
it up and then the next day maybe i mean
it's all possible i don't want to say
it's not not i don't say it's impossible
but
it it is kind of like did he really
plan it out meticulously as he did i i
suppose right that sounds like he'd been
planning it for a while if he if he
organized it so that the gun had arrived
after he turned 18 and everything was
right then it's not like you've been
planning it well let me add so this
issue of planning so in the intelligence
community particularly with terror
attacks we know that there is a planning
process and along that process you end
up finding
ways to intervene they they slip up they
make mistakes there are little warning
signs and from an intel perspective
that's what you look for to stop those
attacks so i think again we're going to
see the more investigative work that
gets done there are those little pops
and flags that we're going to see
retroactively be like we should have
seen that or somebody did see that and
they didn't do something and i think
that's where we're going to start really
making a difference when we
these horrible events happen we learn
from them that's how we stop the next
one it's going to change the next
attack's going to change but that's we
learn yeah you basically what you were
just saying before
uh to add on to that
when i look at these these incidents i
think one of the problems we have is
that we think there's a solution and
maybe there is i'm not saying we
shouldn't try and figure something out
but i wonder if when you know people are
saying we need armed teachers and i'm
like well you know i think if people
were armed in general we'd
we'd probably be better off but i don't
know if that solves the problem of a
deranged young person who plans this
thing out if this dude really did plan
it out as extensively as he did and
seemingly he did because he ordered it
in advance waited until his 18th
birthday saved him money or got a credit
card who knows what he did but he
planned it
then
i don't i don't think
i'll put it this way you mentioned
something before the show you said we
got to be right 100 out of 100 times
because at one time you aren't is when
they get you
so we can we can plan we can be like
okay how about armed teachers and then
the kid just the next the next person
makes a plan to accommodate for arms
teachers i think the issue is that we've
got
a cultural and a mental illness problem
i think that you know i know a lot of
conservatives say mental illness problem
but you look at the medication these
kids are on and we have a fatherlessness
problem
it's cultural and it's and it's
multifaceted amen everybody just wants
the singular solution they're like we
can either ban the guns or you know i'm
the teachers and i'm like that's not
going to solve what's going on well i
think and when it comes to the the
government stepping in
you know
this kid is cutting himself
right um he's made a lot of threats
where's child protective services and
and all i'm going to say is i don't even
have it's not even a question it's more
just an observation but child protective
services were shown up to people's
parent to parents house where they
refused to vaccinate their kids within
hours right then the height of the
pandemic of kovid
child protective services was stepping
in
swiftly so it's just kind of bizarre
that the same government services that
we are looking to protect children in
the case that the parents are not doing
their job
seem to be kind of absent when this is a
very clear case of a kid who is troubled
who is abusive who is uh i mean
if you're 17 and you're cutting yourself
you're cutting your face repeatedly
i mean how much more of a red flag law
do we need to say this kid is not but
boy if he had said my parents won't get
me vaccinated holy crap the child
protective services would have been
there within minutes what if he says my
parents won't let me get my adderall
prescription filled will child
protective services come and take him
will they side with him because he needs
his adderall or will they side with the
parent because it's unconscionable to
give a 14 year old adderall my parents
won't let me choose my pronoun yeah
how would they have swept in and said
the abuse you're creating to this child
so my the reason why i'm bringing this
up is is not to dump on people who are
failing at their job but if you're
turning to the government for a solution
i don't think you're going to have any
solution that works not in this case
it's it's like state of mind the
government is not good at solving state
of mind you need like a spiritual leader
or something or something like that i
think we are in a culture war for a
reason we have very serious cultural
problems now it's cool to see that the
left and right are unified and they're
distant for the police over this one but
when you look at how the left has been
approaching basically everything
i can say
it feels to me the reason moderates and
conservatives are kind of united you've
got post-liberal libertarian centrists
and conservatives all in sort of an
agreement because they're actually
addressing facts and issues the left
isn't you know when it comes to issues
of these shootings they say background
checks i said yesterday okay we have
those oh ban the ar-15 okay what about
an ak what about an m1a what about any
other gun i mean so many
they're just not saying anything but
they're getting really really mad
you know so so i look at the the the
deep cultural issues and and i'm sorry
if i'm not going to take a liberal's
word for it because they believe jesse
smallette and now we have this tweet
going viral from another fake account
claiming that governor abbott sent a rep
to this guy's house
telling him that if you know we'll pay
you to stand with the governor
and if you don't we'll criminally charge
you or something it's the most
ridiculous made up fake story probably
by a 12 year old
joaquin castro's tweeting let me know if
you need any help pulitzer winning
journalists are all tweeting it out like
i can't believe this is happening uh
christopher titus the comedian verified
he's like abbott is done it's like dude
boomers i mean i want to say boomer but
they're not boomers they're like 35
years old and twitter hasn't taken it
down twitter hasn't flagged it right as
misinformation or false
um yeah
but forgive me if i say the people who
believe jesus millette i'm not going to
take political advice from it's just
never going to happen yeah
maybe a lack of critical thinking
because i think they're still getting
facts that's just not right they're
wrong facts whatever that means well
they're not facts yeah like that the ar
means assault rifle for instance and
then they think ban
ban ar you're not gonna have any more
assault rifles so even if you look at
this i think from the most hopeful
perspective people need control and when
you have a moment like this everything
feels out of control so you're going to
gravitate to the thing that makes you
feel best and most comfortable and it's
ar-15 okay that's the bad thing that we
all need to focus our energy on doesn't
matter the nuance or the facts it's just
enough people in the moment of hysteria
say that's the bad thing there's the one
silver bullet solution focus on it and
that's just not true you're bringing up
the very correct points is this is
multi-faceted maybe we have a medicine
issue or sorry
the mental health concern we have a lack
of a father we have a lack of support in
the family there are so many different
pieces to each of these kinds of of
horrific
shootings that to stop and really ask
tough questions
not happening we just want the one
silver bullet solution i want to pull up
this tweet from matt walsh
matt walsh says absolutely damning there
is no defending this 19 officers waited
outside and listened to children get
slaughtered i hope all of these cowards
are sued into bankruptcy they deserve
prison too but i doubt that's going to
happen
let me read for you this excerpt that
matt posted
the authorities now say that local
officers first entered the school at 11
35
two minutes after the gunman and that
there were 19 officers in the hallway by
1203 pm but that they did not breach the
door and killed the gunman until 12 50
even as they continued to hear him
firing i just want to just want to pause
and perhaps tug at your heartstrings
maybe a little bit
i want you to imagine being in the
hallway hearing ten-year-old children
being shot
from a high-powered rifle
and and with 19 people around you armed
and i want you to imagine what must
possibly be going through your head to
think i'm not gonna do anything
i can't fathom that i oh i'm this
wrecked me when i read this tweet
it's wrecking me now i'm wondering what
they knew the cops did they think there
were multiple shooters was it possible
there were multiple shooters that it was
they were firing on purpose in there to
draw them in to kill the cops like what
did they know i think they were gonna i
think what was the first thing they said
but they could have got shot is that
what it was look i'll tell you from from
my view having worked with law
enforcement in the intelligence
community uh when you're going face to
face with uh really awful evil people
um
you just go
and you you get into this line of work
because
you know that you're there
because other people can't be or won't
be and so you take that man along you
know that you're gonna throw yourself
into harm's way and uh the people who
love you your spouses your kids they
know that that's the agreement that you
have it's just in your heart and so
you know the extent to which this did or
didn't happen i don't know but if i i'll
tell you if you had a bunch of guys in a
hallway who knew that this slaughter was
happening
and they put aside their oath and their
commitment to those kids or their
community because they were afraid for
their own lives while at some level i
think most of it can can understand like
hey we want to preserve ourselves
when you sign up to be a law enforcement
official or an intelligence officer you
understand that your body at some level
belongs to the mission and you go you go
in and you know that you will sacrifice
yourself that's just what you sign up
for i don't i don't you know that that
sounds very logical
i don't know that i would be affected in
that way i think the moment i heard
screaming and the guns i'd just be
kicking the door in yeah i can't i can't
i don't think i'd be able to think
straight but that's the point most
people that i've ever worked with in law
enforcement they come to the table with
that orientation in their heart that's
just what they do because they know that
they're going to be called on to do that
it doesn't matter who your kids are or
your spouses or whatever when you hear
that moment when you see that that
person needs to be taken down you go and
you know that you can put yourself in
our heads
real quick sorry man i just have you
ever watched a movie where there's like
medieval warfare or ancient warfare
or even colonial era warfare and i
always thought every mel gibson movie
ever made female games
the patriot is one of my favorite movies
of all time and i when i watch these
movies
i always see those guys on the front
line with the spears or whatever and i'm
like they know they're going to die
and they've they stand there knowing
they are going to die
and it's remarkable because that's
something you choose to walk up to stand
there and say this is it
when when
in this circumstance i'm just like this
is the exact opposite of that yeah these
are the people who are like i'm not
going in front and they they can hear
children being shot i can't i can't
understand i have run into danger for
stupider reasons than that when i worked
for these these media companies and the
we hear the gunshots and we hear the the
flashbangs go off and we take cover and
we slowly try going towards it just to
film it just just to film because we
want to show people what's happening let
alone trying to save the life of a child
i i my brain doesn't understand this i
just don't get it i just can't it it
doesn't the brain doesn't process it
because even if it weren't the gunshots
if they just said on the other side of
this door or some children who were shot
you can't fathom standing there for 30
minutes and saying oh yeah there were
kids shot on the other side of the store
like they knew there were people who had
been shot you you are looking for triage
you're looking to
so it just it just it doesn't make sense
and i'm not saying it didn't happen i i
it just it it defies logic it defies
emotion it defies human nature it defies
the nature of of law enforcement which
does have that race in and save the day
it just it's it's it doesn't i mean
look you've got you left and right
publications are are
essentially unified on the cnn's
reporting they waited in the hallway 19
people
that's just i don't know it doesn't make
any sense i'll tell you working with a
lot of guys in the military uh they will
they have told me stories no doubt
people who are listening to watching
right now probably know what i'm about
to say in terms of when you've got your
brothers next to you
and if there's somebody coming at you
you get up and you fire you take care of
the threat you do it for yourself you do
for the people who are around you
there's a brotherhood and a sisterhood
that you're in this for the mission but
it's also because you're doing this for
your country you know in this way you
know you're doing it for your community
you're doing it for those kids and those
families but you're doing it for your
community because you love your
community you want to defend it from any
threat foreign or domestic it's exactly
the exact same thing in the military you
know those guys do it for their country
because they love their country so i
don't know what the heck has gone on
here but but something is very very
wrong i got ratio today on twitter
because i said this is what this is what
happens when you defund the police you
get incompetent officers
and the response from the right was
these were fully funded officers and
they have no obligation to defend
anybody and the left said the same thing
these are this department was never
defunded and so i'm going to eat that
one and i'm going to own up to the to
the poor wording of the idea
what i was thinking of when i was
tweeting that was
this is what happens after quote-unquote
thief on the police not i i didn't mean
to say that this department was
specifically defunded i said when you
demonize police
when you memorialize criminals
this is what you'll get
why would an officer
they're thinking themselves if i go in
there they're going to blame me they're
going to you know they're going to say
oh he started shooting because you did
it they will throw so no one is willing
to take the actions anymore yeah i was
imagining that from their perspective
maybe in like fog of war they didn't
know what was going on if there were
multiple shooters if it was a hostage
situation if however there are three
guys in there with ar-15s trained on the
door ready for cops just to walk through
one by one and take them down one by one
and they're like we're not going to add
to the bloodshed that's what i'm trying
to figure someone had mentioned that
cops do not rush towards an armed man
that they can't see because they will
get shot
what are we going to say brian this idea
though uh building on what you both have
just said this idea of risk aversion
right so if you right now or in a law
enforcement capacity in this country
you know that if you step incorrectly
you are going to be under a massive
microscope irrespective of your intent
so could there have been an issue here
where some of those people particularly
collectively or like oh god if we do the
wrong thing here or the cameras are
going to be outside and we're all going
to get nailed for this to what extent is
there a risk aversion sort of culture
developing within law enforcement
because of this sort of the the woke
stuff or even some degree of actually
you know good scrutiny over what people
in law enforcement you know have done
historically but has it gone too far has
a pendulum swung too far
i think that that could also potentially
be something that we're looking at here
well the last two democrat presidents
one being the current and the one
before trump
you know the day this happened or two
days ago they were talking about george
floyd and talking about the need for
police accountability so
when you say have we taken it too far
yeah who who wants to be a cop right now
you know and this just makes it worse
right now everyone's you're going to be
a cop did you know 19 of them stood in
the hallway and and now you have to be
collectively joined to that you're all
cops it's like i i i don't want to be
part of that type of cop but i want to
be a cop but not anymore i don't if this
is what it means if every time i do
something you're going to subpoena my
body cam footage to have nbc edit it in
a way that makes me look like the
screw you i don't know we do this for 38
grand a year and we desperately need
heroes right yeah we do yeah if they if
in the military if those soldiers didn't
have the authority to mow down civilians
at will in the heat of the moment
that we would lose every war you need
that vicious
onslaught you need it or you cannot win
a war that's war but these people it
basically was a similar like a war
moment of war in the classroom but i
think this is different but i see what
you're saying you you know you need a
certain level of vigor and and you know
when it comes to outright war
but when you're in war it's different
from when you're hearing children dying
right next to you i
i i i have no words to explain like the
correlation is that their their
authority to be brutal has been stripped
away from them i'm not saying that it's
good for cops to be brutal but i think
that in some cases they need to feel
like they can be in order to survive
now i would only offer brother that i
think that
there is a good thing that we teach both
in law enforcement the intel community
and military and that is target
discernment so understanding who's in
front of you and whether or not to pull
the trigger and i think that a certain
bridling of that raw human nature that
just wants to throttle and kill it's not
such a bad thing actually it's quite
good so some discernment around target
selection is is brilliant but your point
and this is really important in in that
fog of war and that intensity when your
adrenaline is pumping
are you going to make that perfect
decision 100 times out of 100 times
right
no and we know that whether it be in
intel law enforcement or military you're
going to make mistakes and mistakes are
going to happen and so that's when i
think as a as a country we need to be
able to have that moment of reflection
to say
someone made a mistake it doesn't mean
all law enforcement or good or bad or
let's be careful with our statements not
to make speaking swooping
generalizations but maybe a bit more
nuanced but the bottom line i think that
a little bit of target discernment is
really important it's really good but i
think in this case something just didn't
go well it didn't go right it's worse
than you all realize
it's not just about police who stood
back and did nothing from timcast.com
border patrol team who ultimately killed
the shooter were blocked from entering
the school by uvalde police for nearly
an hour why doesn't make any sense
these people were
not only were they cowards but they were
obstructing the parents and the border
patrol
this is something something is wrong
here something's really scary something
is seriously wrong here
now they're saying they they thought the
children were at risk and so they didn't
want to risk it by storming in or
something like that
and now they're saying it was a big
mistake
i don't buy it uh you for you to stand
outside that room hearing gunshots
knowing there are children inside even
if you don't hear gunshots if you know
children had been shot an hour ago right
you still can't go in
there are kids who are shot inside can't
go in what do they think was gonna
happen like he after he killed all the
kids he wasn't a threat anymore he's
still got a gun look let him run out of
bullets first
that's crazy apparently had like what
like 1 600 rounds
we need right now for our future
generations
heroes to look up to
you know what we need we need a story
about
one of these cops what should have
happened
storming in kicking the door in pulling
out their service weapon and
ending this this this
psychopath
and then telling people about how he
risked everything to save these kids and
that's what you want to be when you grow
up yeah well the border patrol agent who
actually did eventually kill him right
was getting his haircut
his wife his wife texted him and said
there's an active shooter in the school
help and i'm sure you can find that
article and he was in the barber shop he
didn't have his uh weapon on him but his
barber had a shotgun holy cow oh the
barber's shotgun and drove to the school
that's amazing he is the one that's the
story you can find the story yeah that
dude needs a move that dude and he's the
one who who eventually killed the
shooter but i'm sure
that is absolutely in the dna of every
cop and every military official and
every cia officer that i've worked with
i would say in the vast majority of
cases that's what drives people to show
up is doing exactly what he did off duty
wasn't his responsibility doesn't matter
it was still his mission because it was
his community it was his country that's
what people dream of when they join the
forces good people dream of having that
moment when they can jump up grab the
nearest available weapon and make it
happen well i wanted to say before we
move to this really interesting sounding
story i think that this might be the
result of what happened during the
pandemic when they were locking down
they were enforcing all these
unconstitutional rules and the good cops
were like i'm out bye so we're left with
cowardly cops who watched what happened
during the vlog
i don't know if he was the guy who
actually killed the shooter they say it
was uh a cbp uh boar tech is that vortec
border tactical yeah that confronted him
but this he this guy did run in with his
barber's shotgun oh he saved his wife
and daughter okay yeah yeah that's
amazing
still
an amazing story and these are the guys
those are the ones we need to make hero
movies yes yep
i mean
how would you do it it would be short
sure it's like it's just a a dad who
said i've gotta i've gotta save my
family you know yeah you know
again what i would love to know is about
this man's life
what
drove him in his life to become who he
became what in his childhood in his
young adulthood what made him decide
that in that moment sit in that barber
chair that he has this beautiful family
that he was going to either try to save
them or he would know that as he was
trying to save his family he could be
shot and killed and he would be gone and
his family would have to survive without
him but he still got himself out of that
chair grabbed that shotgun and ran
there's something interesting and
beautiful about his soul that i would
love to understand because that's
exactly what we need to uplift and
celebrate yeah it's actually a good
origin story for his kid to be like if
you're doing a movie about it about
someone here or like like a marine or a
law enforcement guy did something great
and it's like his origin was that his
dad risked his life and that was the
message he got and that's why he went on
to become a hero i'm gonna tell you what
what this guy is he is a normal man who
did something extraordinary
because that's what in in history of
this country it's not somebody who was
born in some fancy family right it was a
normal person who was put in an
extraordinary situation and did
something extraordinary with the power
of that moment i don't know when i think
of the carries and the bushes and some
of the prestigious families of the
country they've done amazing things
just absolutely it's amazing indeed
i'm definitely amazed when i think about
this yeah he took his barbarous shotgun
he actually helped evacuate people out
of the building well we do we have medal
of honor for uh police local state
police things like that i don't know
maybe we should but i wanted to add
before we move on because our chat's
full of people screaming fed is that
this guy worked for the federal
government he worked for the border
patrol he wasn't a local cop the local
cops didn't do jack deep state
that's it
you raised a great question though the
is there a medal of honor an award will
this guy be recognized it will be
curious the next state of the union is
in uh uh seven months
whoever order patrol whoever the
president invites to his balcony is
always a very important very symbolic i
will bet right now that biden will take
someone from buffalo
to highlight the racism angle because
that is what we do in our politics he
will not take a hero and say this is a
guy who risked everything he will take a
victim and say and it's because of this
country that victimhood like this exists
because you're all bad vote for me again
so that's what i think is going to
happen it's it's a little speculative of
me but uh
i don't think they'll build a statue for
this guy no no but they built a statue
for george floyd yes saint pray for us
saint george who was on fentanyl at the
time of death oh more than that yeah
five he should not have died i mean i'm
not trying to say that in any way but we
don't want to make those guys heroes no
george floyd died and it's tragic and uh
in in many ways you know i also think
that he was a flawed human being
we don't want people just to die but we
don't tell our children to look up to
the people who are who are dying in
these tragic things and who have lived
pretty bad lives
we want kids to look up to this guy
jacob
uh albarado i don't know his name who
was getting a haircut yeah and then
decides he gets a text from his wife
that's the story and then says you know
she says i love you and he rushes in to
help save i mean you want to save his
family but he helps evacuating a bunch
of other people too get jacob alvarado
on the show that is a great idea might
have to try that yeah i think you know
just wait and ask for the question where
did you come from well he's also known
he's also cbp so i'd love to talk to him
oh for sure yeah we'll get a lot of
questions yeah yeah he'll be great guys
ask him if they really whip people oh
yes that's what i want to know i was i
was at uh i went to
austin
and i was hanging out hotel and flipping
through the channels i can't remember
which news station turned on
automatically and it was this
documentary
and it was just the weirdest
jesse smallett level hoax bs leftist
propaganda
and it was playing this dark music and
showing all these awful photos of like
trump supporters and trump looking angry
and then it showed the border patrol guy
with the the rain
please or they tried to convince people
he was whipping them it's just not real
no these people believe jesse smellette
hoaxes every single day jesse's is free
again right like is that that's what i
heard last night he hasn't been put back
in jail well that's right
he's still yeah but you know what's next
i prefer the term administrative state
there you go yes speaking of you were
part of the administrative state i was
that's true why did you leave
uh two reasons the first was uh my
brother was uh
still as an alcoholic but needed to be
in rehab so i left to go make a bunch of
money to get him into rehab so thank god
he's sober and doing better now
the the other uh was i saw a lot of
people
who no longer were there for the right
reasons
i can't talk a lot about the programs
that i was involved in but the upshot is
that they were lying to the white house
and the nsc and the oversight committees
about how successful we were being at
certain things
and i was like you guys are that this is
incorrect
and
they basically just told me to go f
myself right so after a while you know
you were baptized as i was you know born
and raised in rural america my family
loved the country and you know cousins
who joined them you know military and
all that
so joining the cia was an extension of
that so you would have thought as i i
did for many years that everybody would
want to to remain committed to the
mission to the country
but then i got to this level where i'm
involved in various programs and i'm
watching them lie to our elected leaders
which i don't know in hindsight like how
naive of me not to think that some of my
colleagues would lie to protect
themselves so they could get promoted
right but it was so uh just
disheartening that i was like i'm not
gonna spend another 20 years of my life
to around these people who aren't here
for the right reason i i got it i'm out
i'm done so do you think does the cia
have a little bit of an enron problem
where the the numbers are inflated but
everyone likes the cons of the result
and so they're like yeah this is great
great
insider knowledge here every two years
or so people rotate out of positions
so you want to be able in your
evaluation you want people to say oh
things were better than when you got
here nobody wants to say hey when i got
into this position i actually did a
little bit of scrubbing and this is a
bunch of [ __ ]
the programs that we're telling the
downtown that is to say the white house
and congress that are all great actually
they're garbage nobody wants to be that
guy so everybody waits two years and
then leaves so everybody kicks this this
corrupt can down the road and so that's
what's happening inside the agency to
this day so term limits for
administrative state this has been
brought up to me multiple times and i'm
i'm a fan what you're saying is
absolutely solidifies my belief in that
if they're waiting two years to get in a
promotion or to get and they'll just say
whatever they need to say i mean that's
that's the deepest darkest crap
so whether it's i don't know what the
solution is other than uh
you've got to have more sunshine into
those kinds of systems and you have to
have
people you know raise their hand to the
inspectors general etc to say hey
there's an issue but ultimately this is
about the the house and the senate the
oversight committees and their staffs
knowing what questions to ask and
holding the people and power to account
and that's true with the fbi too that's
what has failed over these past number
of years with all these fbi agents who
did this ridiculous crap in michigan you
know setting those those those guys up
uh we saw it with guys like uh john
brennan
who knew damn well that there was no
trump russia collusion but he left the
agency and he went around the country
for two years saying it was all but true
if not absolutely true and he knew it
wasn't i knew oh james clapper as well
sorry
he had another one clapper with when
they're talking about the prism spying
network that they had uncovered and
asked if they'd been spying on american
people his response was not wittingly
knowing full well yes you have been
spying on the americans built a big
station like a big building in the
middle of nowhere to do it under oath he
perjured himself congress did nothing so
here's here's what the deep state is i'm
going to give you an example a guy named
aldridge ames he was a cia officer back
in the 1990s and he decided he was going
to spy for the soviet union and so he
did and he was caught by the fbi and
they asked him aldrich why'd you do it
and he said because i know
what's best for this country and its
national security and i'm going to act
on it
so the deep state are these people have
profound powers
who decide that based on their own
politics their own beliefs they're going
to do whatever the hell they want to do
irrespective of the law and then they
get away with it so was it like a
corporate governance basically that got
built in 1946 is that right after world
war ii eisenhower basically put this
thing together that's the up the upshot
yeah through the second world war there
was something called the oss that was
kind of the external intelligence
service and then obviously the fbi
proceeded that but um yeah it was this
uh
there was a need
for foreign intelligence to understand
what our adversaries are doing and to
get ahead of that right so i get the
need and that remains but the problem is
when you give people and any human power
some percentage of them are going to
abuse it and the more power that you
give them
at some level you're going to have more
and more people who abuse it it's just
the nature of humanity so how do you how
do you bridle that how do you manage it
and there are different people who
answer that in different ways maybe you
don't do it at all because it's just too
risky so you get rid of the cia all
together or yeah you manage it better i
always wonder if the deep state is the
and correct me
the organization itself is so big and so
well entrenched that by the time there's
a new president and they switch out john
podesta for who's the guy now bill
barber bill burr is the comedian yeah
hopefully it'll be bill berson that
would be fun
by the time you swap these people out it
doesn't matter who's at the top like i'm
doing my thing and you know he doesn't
know i exist i know who he is just to
stay out of his hair is there some truth
to the fact that the apparatus is so big
that the people at the top they rotate
no one cares that's absolutely true and
this gets back to the point that was
made about the the the whether it be
term limits uh even in your your
bureaucracy or mid-level guys or or it's
just a size issue you you just expanded
the state in the past 20 30 years to
such an extent that that there are so
many people who have so many entrenched
interests that a it slows down your
mission but then b you get more and more
people who can do more and more damage
to your country because you give them
such expansive powers so i'm a big fan
of actually reducing not just the size
of government generally speaking which
it's true but specifically the the deep
state as it were the agency the fbi i
certainly think the administrative state
the deep state whatever you call it is a
serious problem
but uh
what about the argument and i'm not
saying it's a good argument i'm just
saying this is the argument made that if
we curtail our powers internationally
and domestically china will take over
and then we'll be living in a unipolar
chinese superpower you know planet so
here's the deal cia ain't going to stop
this yet uh china the cia and the fbi
are not going to stop china
the fbi starts at least 10 cases every
day against china right now we have over
a hundred thousand chinese nationals who
come into this country every year so the
issue isn't
it is like a damn
that's bursting we're trying to put our
finger in it to stop it
you have good leadership within the
white house and the house and the senate
that understands that china is a threat
and starts treating them as such the
spies ain't gonna fix this one the fbi
ain't gonna fix this they just won't so
we don't need to expand the
administrative state to fix this problem
it's a political problem you have to
understand that china hates us they're
trying to destroy us we are their
enemies and so you start
changing that relationship so for
instance you take your damn economy out
of china
do you think trump could have stopped
china i think he tried with his his
trade deal i mean he basically said look
you guys start buying more of our stuff
because you're stealing our stuff right
so that's the thing that right now
people are forgetting
biden is actually thinking about getting
rid of the tariffs but trump actually
said look no the tariffs ultimately are
about saying to the chinese you still
steal billions of dollars of our economy
our intellectual property every [ __ ]
year so you're going to start paying
more through these tariffs or it's a
penalty right so now biden's going to
get rid of them well then what lesson
have the chinese
learned yeah they can keep stealing us
so so my question i suppose was
if trump was working towards ending
this expanding dominance of the chinese
economy and taking of our infrastructure
our manufacturing things like that i
should say our economic infrastructure
and the spies weren't able to stop it
but they were able to stop trump they've
effectively cropped up china they've
they've secured our doom on the global
stage
yeah i will point out it's uh not china
though it is the ccp the occupying force
of that land well amen the actual
government of china is a republic of
china located in taiwan and they are in
very good terms with what's right what
would your deep state say if you are
right thank you sir what would the deep
state say if china unleashed this like
let's just call it a virus
and like it went worldwide would there
be penalties
fcc obviously the chinese people are men
they're they're stuck under that
totalitarian they are occupying forces
for real right now and mao like seized
control but but removing the economy
from china we saw during covet how
90 95 of our pharmaceutical is is based
in china
nothing has been done to change that now
we look at similar geopolitics we look
at ukraine and we say boy this was
really bad that we import 60 percent of
our fertilizer from from russia nothing
will change about that we used to
produce our own pharmaceuticals we used
to produce our own fertilizer the whole
gulf coast was where we got them
why did we ever move these industries
overseas and show me one person in the
senate and there are lots of pro-america
i hate china i hate russia senators and
they're all on the right show me one of
them who is making a concerted effort to
say i don't care what the global market
says astrazeneca pfizer merck uh you
know fertilizer all of you have to come
back to america because there is a there
is a geopolitical and national security
risk to having these critical you want
to get your olive oil from italy that's
great get your cheese from france
totally cool but your fertilizer can't
be made by your enemy nor can your
aspirin but there is not one serious
piece of legislation to bring or
movement to bring all these things back
to america none whatsoever well just
watch china do it again and say wow that
was really bad but you know thanks for
my iphone so this is
maybe i'm just uh uh to be honest a
circle surface level dude i'm sitting
here reading the internet thinking i
know so much about you know geopolitics
and international conflict and i assume
there's probably some cia or fbi guy
sitting in his in his in his office with
all this classic information just
laughing being like oh if only you
really knew maybe that's the case i hope
but but i i do i do because i want to be
right exactly i want to believe they're
sitting there saying like here's why we
had to do what we did because we are
concerned about china taking over we are
concerned about these these uyghur camps
we're concerned about the belt and road
initiative we're concerned about oil
exploration in south america but really
what it feels like is
trump derangement syndrome went viral
within these these agencies
trump actually was doing things that
were good on foreign policy
and they stopped him
they stopped him and that's the problem
of the deep state the administrative
state you know what the media tries to
do they try to make you think the deep
state is a cabal of people who meet
below dc with robeson and have like a
pentagram on the ceiling no it's just
that people who get jobs hollywood
that's right
what it actually is that's why that's
why ian brought up administrative states
it's people who don't get fired
they're they're working there for 20
years between a bunch of different
presidents and you know obama gets
elected he sits down and they say here's
what's happening and here's our plan and
the president goes okay i guess dude and
so they just do whatever they want as
long as they want j edgar hoover was the
head of the fbi for 48 years 47 some
years like he ran the country he was
running the country 47 years he headed
the it was ahead of the fbi i mean i've
never been in the fbi but i mean what's
the power i would imagine that power
level is immense
amen so particularly without going into
the history of the fbi he absolutely
decided the political winners and losers
of this country and that's really what
happened during the the 2020 and 2016
election particularly 2016 with hillary
clinton and trump right so
after trump was elected you had a bunch
of former cia and fbi officials james
comey leaking classified information to
force the appointment of a special
counsel
holy crap yeah i mean this is one man an
fbi director who decided that trump
should not be in power
not because there was actual data or
information that said we had a problem
but he just didn't like the guy so he
goes to the new york times leaks it in
order to get bob mueller that is j edgar
hoover level stuff and we haven't seen
that in a long long time i foolishly
believed that we those dark days were
over but that showed me that not it
ain't gone there were still absolutely
people in positions without authority
and power who still do this jack or
hoover's the sussman trial stuff is
crazy yeah we had cash battle the other
day
and uh
it's just shocking the fbi knew it was
bunk almost immediately you had
apparently one guy testified that
hillary clinton knew and signed off on
on the russia gate narrative fabrication
wow
the the the the agents as assessment
himself who who lied on the fisa warrant
to get these um um
against paige to get the fisa yeah so
that that's the same guy it is the same
level of of
corruption and negligence and evil and
dereliction of duty on a different level
but it's the same idea as the 19 guys in
texas who stood in the hallway and
listened to the gunshots this is exactly
what your mission is and you're like
yeah but i'm not gonna do it like you
know this is a lie yeah but i'm not
gonna do it like you know what your job
is right now and the oath you have taken
yeah i'm gonna do the opposite
you know i'll tell you on one piece that
in the last couple weeks i i did on my
podcast and talked a lot about that that
doesn't i think get enough attention 107
000 people last year died because of
fentanyl or drug overdoses most of them
of the 107 000 were fentanyl the point
is most of that comes from china those
are precursor chemicals that come from
china china knows
these companies that are producing it
they know that they in turn are dealing
with mexican cartel members
and it's then all feeding into this
country china is killing a hundred plus
thousand of our people
why are we not all like outraged that
that the the communist government in
beijing is doing this in concert in
collaboration with mexican cartels it is
just it should be getting far more
attention certainly than even ukraine i
mean as much as that that
absolutely runs the risk of world war
three and i think we can talk about that
as well because i think we're getting
there
that issue of dead americans in this
country especially in rural america is
so real and so painful for me personally
but for so many others it's it deserves
more of our attention and that's why
because it's rural america and we were
saying to this before the show started
if the overdoses of from fentanyl and
chinese opioids
uh were upper east side uh collegiates
this would have been stopped by now but
it's mostly rural mostly poor mostly
hillbilly whites and we don't really
care they targeted the farmers it's just
exactly it is not a population the
american government care about because
they don't like them even their own
their representatives don't like them
look for any liberal who represents a
rural state who's running for office
even they are ashamed of their
constituency they don't care but i'm
gonna tell you right now in pima county
arizona where i am from
if you were a kid the the thing that's
going to get you in terms of the thing
that's going to kill you is fentanyl
right now it's not car accident it's not
it is fentanyl and pima county is not a
rural you know white hillbilly area it's
you are right the preponderance is
absolutely that is true but it's hitting
communities in lots of parts of this
country black brown it doesn't matter it
is hitting our young people most
especially because that [ __ ] part of my
language is mixed up with weed or with
other stuff and they're like hey let's
experiment let's try and have a good
time and then they end up dead because
there's just such tiny amounts of that
they never killing you i find it to be
an extension of the opium wars
apparently this is when the british and
other europeans were shuffling opium
into china they were basically
colonizing china in the mid-1800s and
they're like we're going to wreck their
population make them incapable of
fighting then we're going to conquer it
and take it as another colony like what
they did with india but the chinese
eventually fought back and pushed them
back to the coast and off and into
taiwan or hong kong or these these
islands um but it never ended for them
they play the long game any any wise
regime thinks hundreds of years in the
future and will never never forget
what's what people are capable of and
that's what they're doing they're
sending it into mexico like you said
with the cartels using them to run it up
into the country they're destabilizing
our youth you see it in the
you know dysphoria movement um you see
in the shootings
and the the pharmaceutical companies
seem to be capitalizing on it they've
actually created medical fentanyl you
can i mean i don't know who's in charge
is it astrazeneca who who actually
prints this stuff this this stuff
they're working colluding with the ccp
i want to talk to you guys about guns
because i had this tweet this friday so
i want to talk about my tweet
i tweeted the government should provide
all 16 year olds with a free ar-15 after
they pass firearm ed in high school oh
yeah if you haven't then once you turn
18 you should be entitled to one free
ar-15 from the government after passing
a general knowledge test department of
gun services demand universal gun
ownership now call your member of
congress and demand they pass this
legislation a lot of people said that i
was trolling i'm not my point was that i
saw all these memes from the left where
they said we should treat guns like we
treat cars
and i was like you think that goes only
one way they post these memes where
they're like gotta get a license gotta
get insurance gotta register the gun all
of that stuff and i was like okay i can
use that same argument go the other
direction
we allow 16 year olds to drive cars
okay so 16 year olds should get guns we
also have gun rights in the constitution
so you want to argue for universal
health care i'll argue for my universal
uh demand as well government should pay
for my guns but let me tell you where
where the juicy part of the tweet is at
karl marx said
under no pretext should workers
surrender their arms and ammunition the
true leftist position on guns should be
an armed workforce and the government
providing guns to the people it's just
simple logic karl marx right he said
never surrender your arms and ammunition
well if you're a socialist you don't
think capital is going to fund the
creation of these guns do you it's going
to be the government and they're going
to provide it tim did aoc retweet this i
is that what i'm seeing did she like and
retweet
no i'm saying no she will no
you know that's strange why not i think
the only problem i have with this tweet
is that i don't think getting your gun
from the government is the best thing
because if they really want to conquer
you they'll make the gun have a defect
and then give it to you and they know
how to exploit the defect i'm not saying
the only place to get the gun oh okay
i'm saying you get a free one so it's a
net possible
and you've got to get you you'll
probably want to get it checked out but
universal gun ownership they want to
argue for universal health care i'm like
okay cool well they say health care is a
human right i say gun ownership is a
human right right okay well then the
government can pay for it and give
everybody guns
there we go any objections no all right
there it is
your right to own does not dictate a
right to receive well of course i agree
okay yeah sorry for the logic i think my
only question is
at the 30 000 foot level what are we
considering the age of adulthood so if
it's 16 and i know you can drive at 16
some places in rural you can get your a
farmer's license to drive a heavy
equipment at 14. you can't go on the
road but you can drive a 500 000 combine
right pretty awesome um
but but
there's another movement though to move
the gun ownership age to 21. and i have
a problem with uh
voting at a certain age
but voting on something that you cannot
fully own and free society at another
age because are you
i don't want to be able to vote at 18
but i can't own something until i'm 21.
there's the movement as you were saying
to vote at 16. so 16 year olds are gonna
make law or vote for laws but i can't
fully participate in that law for five
more years so if we're gonna have a real
equitable society to use their words
then if you have the right to vote on
something you must have the ability to
have full participation in that agree if
we're gonna make the voting age 16 then
the gun age is 16 but then the draft is
16 but i don't want my 16 year old
sending my 21 year olds to war telling
the 18 year olds they can't have a
cigarette a beer or a gun so something
is wrong if we're going to say the age
of adulthood now is 21 and we are a very
immature society then it's 21 across the
board i have a i have a darker
interpretation of their desire for a 16
year old voting age well they're stupid
well no offense to them listening it's
not just stupidity it's if you're an
adult at 16 that means you can do more
than vote yeah that's what i'm thinking
it's a slippery slope because at what
point can you have sex with a 35 year
old you know 16 years now what are they
trying to do this is why when they try
and lo lower the age of adulthood in a
variety of ways i'm kind of like what's
what are you really doing
when you when you look what's going on
in these schools
you know the grooming
and i see these memes from these
liberals on facebook where they
desperately try to conflate the grooming
argument with banning books and it's
just like i see this meme and it's you
know they want to ban books and there's
like an old man with a maghet yelling
and i was like i think they were
concerned about the graphic depictions
of adult activities and those books that
were available to children
if you're defending that yeah and and
you're doing out of ignorance
or it's willful
then either way the outcome is the same
when you come out and then say
kids should be you know participating in
governance at 16. it's like
you're you're creating a threshold for
which we reduce the age of adulthood
um i i look i don't know if 18
you know where that number comes about
because it's certainly 200 years ago was
you know you were you're 13 you're
considered a man or whatever i don't
know if i agree with that 18 kind of
feels okay you know gun ownership and
all these things
you can be under 18 and have a gun if
your parents take responsibility for it
in most places like in wisconsin and
stuff like that
i mean you know growing up uh family
farm we hunted you know from when i was
a very young boy but that was part of
our culture we were taught how to use a
firearm respect a firearm and so it's uh
this idea that a 16 year old couldn't or
a 14 year old couldn't i mean use a
firearm and be taught how to use it
thoughtfully is just it's bizarre to me
because i grew up in that culture yeah
yeah so i was shooting from the time i
was like 10 years old yeah my dad took
us we had like a little shooting range
in our back 40
probably not really on on par with what
the law wanted but my dad taught us how
to use it he taught us how to be safe
with it he said i'll give you a dollar
if you ever see the end of this gun
while i'm holding it and of course he'd
never gave us a dollar because we never
saw it and we understood how important
that was but somebody on twitter earlier
today i forget who it was i'm sorry
tweeted how many of these mass shooters
were young boys raised by fathers who
taught them how to hunt it's a very
valid question i don't think any of them
ever have been they don't they have no
debts of course not yeah it's very sad
so that's why when i in the days after
these shootings and we hear congress
stand up and say we need to pass this
law or that law this is the stuff this
is the conversation that we need to have
as a country understanding who these
individuals are their families the
dynamics the health you know mental
health all that because you are so
writing whoever said uh tweeted that
bravo to them because that's spot on
yeah and and i remember thinking um i
actually had this conversation before i
left the healthcare field with one of my
co-workers um and his dad wasn't really
involved in his life and there was a
shooting and i was like this is terrible
but man i think one of the things that
all of these shooters have in common is
that they don't have dads and he's like
huh that's weird i really have to think
about that he's like that's a super hot
take i'm like i think it's true sorry
it's afraid it's a couple things it's a
dad
to sit down with you and say son you
need to understand responsibility and
what it means to be to have you know to
have obligations to your community and
it's also the moment when the dad pops
you on the head and said that was dumb
what do you feel stupid yeah yeah i'm so
strong leader dad to be like how are you
feeling
yeah are you okay yeah maybe like a dad
who's got like long hair and it's like a
hippie with a bunch of crystals yeah
maybe you used to smoke weedness
oh yeah
look but the point the point here is
that i think that this conversation is
just as valid as hey what about uh
magazine limitations what about the the
type of weapon you know or what about
the age that we should give children of
right i think this conversation is just
as important if not more important but
you hear of so oftentimes from the left
they will say oh here hear the right you
know hear the conservatives go again
talking about family issues and about
you know
knock it off come on it's absolutely it
should be part of the conversation
we should have a magazine limit i i
really do think so they shouldn't that
we should limit them to what to uh uh
they cannot be lower than that
at least yeah i knew
look at society for the last four
generations or so so from like the baby
boomers on
and we're going to say that gun violence
uh guns school shootings are are the now
the anomaly well we have to look at that
in context right and that's just all
they want to look at is like wow
suddenly gun uh there are incidents of
shootings at schools uh therefore it's a
gun problem well what else is happening
concurrently right i mean you can't just
take one in one statistic
and then an isolated and when you look
at everything else that's happening
clearly fatherlessness is a huge problem
sexual perversion is a huge problem you
know what i love about liv libs of tock
which is why they got banned from
twitter is i just wish you would find
some liberal teachers who were so
enthusiastic about math and science as
they are about their genitals yeah these
teachers indeed these teachers making
non-stop videos about telling their kids
and i told my girl and it's like dude
like do you ever talk to them about
reading right so so if you look at again
all these millions of statistics of five
generations you can't just look at the
shootings and say wow that's an anomaly
it's a gun problem there's lots of other
things that are spiking and if you say
that while they're not happening there's
no correlation then you're just a liar
or you're politically motivated either
the sexual perversion stuff is is a huge
problem you mentioned the grooming stuff
yeah i mean we have we have hardcore
drag shows
in in children's you know second grade
classroom and and
and we're supposed to pretend this is
normal
quite frankly and this is going to sound
hard and i i don't want it to come out
the wrong way i'm surprised there are
not more school shootings because our
kids are so messed up in the head
they're told boys can get pregnant
they're they're
they have tampons in their bathroom they
play on girls teens
these kids are so confused with
everything and then their teachers don't
even want to talk about english and math
they want to talk about their dating
lives and and in case anyone out there
starts to text you do know i am married
to a guy yeah right so i intently i'm in
the community it's a community i hate
it's an alphabet soup that is
degenerative that drives me insane but
but we have to talk about these things
you're you're the the way the the
oppression olympics go you're you're out
i'm not a good one yeah you're you're a
you're a victim but i mean i mean
there is a role for me to play in this
because
you a lot of people you cis people can't
have these conversations the cisgender
you are scissors am i cis yes oh crap
what does cis mean so not trans not
trans so uh ian and i first oh good
yeah yeah yeah yeah i knew it was
somewhat whatever
what you mean to say is says hat
yeah not so cisgender heteronormative
you are not
all these different words i don't even
know what they mean they don't even have
meaning people will create them like
they don't have any i got no problem
with that to telling it evolves yeah if
if a group of yeah language evolves if a
group of people are like if someone
isn't trans what are they they call it
sis it's like a math thing i'm like yo i
literally don't care what words you use
as long as you're effectively conveying
ideas to each other are we but the
problem is it's not just the creation of
new words it's the it's the
corruption of existing words like racism
right that that's been a huge problem
for a long time as to what racism really
means
now
people can come out and say cis and
trans and whatever and i'm like as long
as i understand you we can have a
conversation but we don't understand
each other right ricky gervais is being
cancelled from netflix because of his
transphobic jokes but they they're not
transphobic but no they're jokes about
trans people there are jokes about
polish people there are jokes about
catholics but he didn't he didn't get
booted did he
they they were threatening to you know
pull him i'm sure netflix can't afford
to have anymore netflix fired their
diversity people i'm pretty sure he's
safe he's safe
but i mean it's not a transphobic joke
it's a joke about trans people and if
you're getting made fun of welcome to
the friggin club you know it's like i
remember talking to a mormon when book
of mormon came out and he was saying
that he found a very offensive book of
mormon i was like as a catholic let me
tell you it's about damn time someone
else's religion was made fun of by
mainstream culture so welcome to welcome
to being like everyone else you know
that's what that's what he said ricky
gervais said he thinks trans people
should have rights and be treated like
everyone else and that's why he's going
to make fun of him boom
he's like that's what true equality is
it is it means if everybody is equal
then everybody is fair game for for
being mine i talked about this a little
bit on pop culture crisis a couple days
ago where we were talking like if
someone like if a soldier loses a limit
in the military in the war or something
you don't like ha ha
you
losing your like you you don't smash
people for what they what they don't
have but
and maybe people feel like that they're
like i'm not normal so you're making fun
of my non-normalcy and that's really
like getting me where i can't defend
myself i get that but at the same time i
don't like like make be making other
people the butt of my jokes i kind of
stopped doing that just in general
although you know one of the things i if
i can so i have hung out with a ton of
guys in the military who have lost arms
and legs because of iraq and afghanistan
and i've also hung out with tons of guys
who are in the military and they're gay
or we we have lesbian service members
whatever it may be
the way that you know that you are in
with that group is with somebody makes a
crack at you yeah that's right i i was
with a guy about 15 guys at a black
rifle coffee company most of those guys
that they hire have have lost limbs
they uh some of those guys when they
walk in you know they'll be like their
legs their arms are really loud and
noisy because they're half [ __ ]
robots right the point is they will make
fun of each other about like hey quiet
down man you're rude we're trying to
have a conversation right he's like
sorry it's my knee you know but they'll
give each other a hard time and it's
this beautiful moment of like you know
that you it you are in a family a
brotherhood by just getting telling good
jokes about it there's a really great
wojack meme where it's uh a guy is
leaving and he's like he's like see you
later [ __ ] and they'll like screw
off you know a-hole and then it's like
fu and then as soon as he's gone they're
like that's a cool dude
then it shows the women oh gosh and no
one's like bye honey love you you're so
sweet see you soon and then as soon as
she's gone what a [ __ ]
that's why i don't that's why i have
fewer females friends i think but i
wanted to say too that it does feel
great when somebody makes a joke with
you about something that maybe you can't
even change that you're just like oh
yeah that's actually pretty funny and i
feel now like i'm part of your in-group
it's very valuable
so much of it oh sorry to interrupt
there at the end
capitalize on what you were saying it's
the delivery like if you can deliver it
in an emotionally in a loving way then
it's received in a loving way but when
it's in text no one can comment
amen and they'll take gervais's jokes
and they'll put them in text and be like
look how horrible yes yeah yeah and
he the the performance has a full arc
how did he get to that point there was a
segue they cut all that out and they
just take the sentence and they're like
context but i just love how all the hit
pieces against ricky gervais
are literally what he was complaining
about yeah he was actually talking about
the woke cancel culture and how they're
demanding special privileges because
they don't want to be made fun of but he
was like but everybody is is equal so
we're all gonna be made fun of and then
they write articles saying he's
transphobe and he's violent and he's
dangerous
absolutely absurd yeah but i mean the
alphabet soup which is really run by by
just communists um like like all
minority groups
uh in in in activism right now
you can't have it both ways you can say
this immutable characteristic makes us
so special and so unique and so
different that we have to celebrate it
but we also want to get treated like
everybody else right if you want to get
treated like everybody else that stinks
because when you treat like everybody
else you're standing in line right we
all want you know
like
emerald club status at the airport so
that we can bypass all the lines and we
can have a fancy drink but equality is
not fun so the the alphabet two people
like we want our special and god it's
almost june one and then i have a whole
thing
no oh but don't worry don't worry flip
your uke your ukraine flag and put up
that's right if you're private
just unfollow all the brands and follow
the saudi arabian ones and you're good
i love it you said something earlier
daniel that was really interesting where
you said you were almost surprised that
there weren't more shootings i am i
don't want to take a wave too much from
where we're headed with the jokes and
enriquez i love this conversation but i
i i've had that same thought like why is
it not but then i'm thinking about
people driving on the road and how so
many people drive past each other all
day on the road over and over these
thousand or you know hundreds of miles
it's 140 miles different 70-70 and they
don't hit each other because they don't
want to and most people don't want to
hurt each other that's very very very
rare and it's more of an aberration on
these kids that's causing it i don't so
it's i'm actually not surprised that
there's but
they're trying not people don't want
that that's like look at the desperation
tactic it can reach a point so uh
northern ireland for instance i remember
i was getting a tour of northern ireland
and there's like a memorial for when you
know a group of guys went shot and
killed another group of guys
and you know on one side of town they're
like these guys were heroes and other
side of town like these guys were
villains
and it's just like there was no reason
to do that they didn't earn or gain
anything it was just pure tribalism
you can look at the literal tribalism
with you know what we've seen in africa
where one day one tribe goes out and
starts beating and killing the other
tribe for almost no reason just the
hatred within them when you start to see
some of these tweets where there was one
guy said i wish all republicans get
cancer and die excruciating deaths it's
getting scary it's getting to this point
where
you know you turn on the tv and you know
msnbc is not even trying to talk to you
but i mean even we do it we we know
there's a group of people who don't care
to watch us or even listen to what we
have to say so we just eventually tune
them out but this creates separate
spaces which which is ripe for you know
developing a hatred more and more for
the opponent for the other and that's
the problem with with a lot of our
elected leaders and
you know
biden is president right now so you can
say well you told me trump was president
that's a hypothetical biden is president
and he had his moment
after this shooting to say something and
what he chose was nothing but division
and attacking his political enemies he
did not offer the slightest sense of
healing of sorrow he didn't even evoke
the names and memories of these kids and
talk about you know just an evil in
society he talked about the nra and he
talked about republicans who won't pass
comments he resurrected 40-year-old
talking points it might have been the
election of 1976
right and so i agree with you you know
we are falling into these rival camps
but if our leaders don't start i want
wanna pull up this uh this tweet thread
from
zack seward who is the i believe he's
the editor-in-chief at quartz who posted
one of the most deceptive falsely framed
articles i've ever seen such a lie it's
a really good example of the problems we
face yes before i start this by
criticizing the mainstream media for
lying to you i want to point out that
there absolutely are conspiracy
theorists and lunatics and cult members
on the right they exist sure but they're
not vc funded they don't have investors
who are giving them all of this money
there are some small right wing outlets
conservative outlets that do get funding
but they're not nearly as bad as this
they they wrote a story we ordered the
same gun used in uvalde here's how easy
it was
he says it was just like ordering
groceries click checkout done
he's getting roasted for this seriously
because while in the piece that does
mention you have to go through a
background check and all that stuff the
way they frame it is incredible take a
look at this he says
at no time where we ask for proof of age
or of a clean criminal record both of
which are legally required to buy a
firearm
that will happen when we pick up the gun
at our local licensed dealer that's
right the headline is everything
here's how easy it was they're trying to
convince you not only that but he goes
on to say it was an assault rifle he
says some people don't know how easy it
is to go online and buy an assault rifle
he didn't buy one though he did not buy
an assault rifle it's just
a
misrepresentation and this is what leads
people who are traditional liberal or
trusting in the news into believing
wrong information so what this tells me
is he's not actually interested in
having a thoughtful conversation it's
about an agenda right so very clearly
this is about
creating this drum beat this hysteria to
ban not just this gun but really all
guns right so it's it's a war then on
guns and if if in fact that's the idea
then the question becomes particularly
from that outlet that we know as a lefty
outlet
why do they want to remove all guns is
it really just about trying to save the
kids in school i'm not so sure that's
true i think most people would say
there's probably another agenda here so
that kind of headline by the way we know
that americans uh rarely read down into
an article i think that that is around
60 or 70 percent of people only read the
headline and then the remainder of that
is only the first paragraph so very i
think three or five percent people
actually read the whole story so these
folks know that i want to give a shout
out to a journalist this is a story i i
did uh i covered
uh just almost three years ago i
remember this from business insider this
journalist wrote i tried to buy a gun at
walmart twice and roadblocks left me
empty-handed both times
this was actually a good story and i
give credit to this journalist she had
um you know misconceptions about what
buying a gun was like she went to a
walmart and said i'm going to see what
happens and when she got road blocked
she wrote that she was good for her this
is like one of the biggest segments i've
ever done it's got 2.7 million views
i've i'm surprised but
you know i i didn't criticize her and le
mancha i was like this is great a
reporter actually decided to investigate
what it's like to get guns because they
weren't familiar with it and they were
honest with their audience about not
being able to buy one
that's that's the reality yeah
the the shocking thing about courts is
that
there are
two dozen outlets just like that right
between
courts and noxios and mother jones and
and you just go on and on and on and
they're all they're all the same and
they're all funded by
basically the same venture capitalist
lefty ideologue billionaires they all
have the same agenda they're all
intermarried right which is weird
they're all they all know each other
kind of like the uh um the the one
conspiracy not that conspiracy the one
thought is who the leaker is of the
supreme court document when went through
of you know who's married to who and who
was a bridesmaid and who's waiting they
all know each other um it's a caste
system there's no one on the there are
very few outlets on the right of this
side there are a couple right we know
them the beacon the daily caller they're
great publications but they're they're
they're paltry in number compared to
right left and
you look at the the the funding that
goes into these left-wing
democrat or whatever publications
hundreds of millions of dollars
and then you look at right-wing
publications who sometimes get some
funding but not really yeah what was
that cia program where uh they were
working directly with media was that was
that mockingbird yeah yeah i think it is
yeah there's two of them i'm pretty sure
i thought you were gonna ask me about
the time that we uh operated on the cat
and the cat was going to be actually a
listening device
did it survive that's another one
that's a real thing that is that is true
yes so this is what they did they
actually put the the the listening
device in the ear and then they use the
antenna and they built another part in
the back kind of in between the
shoulders
and they what they did is they took the
cat because hey it's just a cat it's
innocuous and they took the cat and they
uh they set it next to two gentlemen to
test it on a on a park bench i know what
happened i think and unfortunately kitty
kitty did not stay there of course not
to listen
so the cat
ran
unfortunately in front of a taxi oh no
oh my gosh
cat didn't want to be part of it nope
the kitty kitty for the cat did not
survive ultimate
you can't sacrifice a cat to join the
deep state no
they are
individuals so no but speaking of
mockingbird which i brought up um
what the heck this is from 1948 i mean
this has been going on for a long time
the cia basically right after formation
was like we've got to control the media
it's not just mockingbird we talked
about this with luke rodkowski if we are
change there was something that happened
in the 70s where a senator i think came
out and said the cia is working directly
at these news outlets yeah
do you know mockingbird well so there
was a huge dust up throughout the 70s
where basically the the the house and
the senate were like you guys are doing
way too much that you in the cia and
they had committee hearings so frank
church was one of the senators lead from
idaho and there were others they looked
into this and the cia director they
called them on the carpet both overtly
that is to say out in public and then
and behind the curtain and like you guys
are killing way too many people uh
without authorization and you you a
bunch of cowboys and and some of these
uh programs that you're talking about
were part of that conversation that we
need to rein you in because we've given
you too much power and y'all are abusing
it and it's not just you the cia it's
the president and all the president's
men as it were who were like hey you
know with the military we can't do
certain things but we can use this tool
at the cia and we can have them go kill
various people or foment on rising
uprisings etc right or yes the media
piece we can start to control and
manipulate and so again it gets back to
this if you give people power some
percentage of them are going to abuse it
but if you give them a whole bunch of
power it is game on in terms of your
country and that's really for me when
the past five ten years has completely
changed my understanding of giving so
much power to the cia or nsa or fbi they
will abuse it they have abused it and
we've got to pull that back both in
terms of the size and the authorities
because they have too much still a lot
of great people doing great work at
those places but you give them too much
power and you're going to have these
problems and our country is in trouble
because of it yeah i think a lot about
the people because i i speak a lot of
crap about the administrative state and
like how it's overblown but i think the
people the other night i was like i
don't want to hurt these people like not
that like the the horseback riders in
1902 i mean the automobile was coming
they still lost their jobs yeah
i don't want to see these people lose
their gigs and the problem is when
they're the ones that control the
assassination attempts anyone that's
going to try and unseat them from their
gig is a is a real threat
has a big like yo you don't want to
anger people that control the button
like
basically but
if it is i mean
you think we'd be better better off
without
these organizations i think i think of
the fed in michigan who's who's doing a
covert op and he's on a chat room with
some guy he was like i hate governor
whitman i think we should assassinate
her and he's like let's play and let's
plan the kidnapping you know and then
they're having meetings and then all of
a sudden at no point people like wait a
second we're actually going to plan to
kidnap the governor just to trap this
one loot
aren't we taking this a little too far
guys
you know they're they're ordering vans
and someone's going to hurts and they're
picking up a rope and it's like i think
we're getting a little too excited about
kidnapping the governor guys like i know
we want to catch this bad dude but this
is getting a little crazy i i so
i don't at what point does yeah when you
say they need to be reined in i think
that's an example of reigning it in and
it kind of strikes me bizarre that no
one in the hierarchy was like i think
you guys need to slow down the
kidnapping plan
this is a little crazy would it look
more like if it was raining in would it
be like this this nsa no longer exists
like what was the nsa form 2000 2001 was
it after 911 or has it been around
longer than that it's been around longer
but yeah look i here's where i come down
on this i think it's absolutely
reasonable based on what we have seen
over the past 10 plus years certainly
since the the 2016 election it's
reasonable for people to say
the the intelligence community has grown
too big and too powerful just like it
did back in the 1970s we need to remove
some of the authorities we need to have
more oversight because we recognize that
there might be a need for collection of
foreign intelligence to understand what
our adversaries are doing fine or a
domestic
law enforcement capacity we need to find
some bad guys here in the country
fine
but it's gotten too big and there's too
much power and we need to pull that back
in and that happens after we have the
house and the senate if they actually
functioned they would do the
investigations into that to figure out
how bad the problem is and then we
figure out how deeply we have to rein it
in absent a functional congress
that's when the the american media is
supposed to do the work do that
investigative work to expose some of
this stuff but when you have a media
that is so in the tank
for you know folks particularly on the
left then what what's their incentive to
actually get to the bottom of some of
these abuses that's there's no outside
function right now that's keeping power
in check the house the senate nope the
president nope our media nope that's the
problem of this moment and i think it's
compounded by the fact that
no offense you all seem to be really bad
at your job i mean in the sense that
it's like
shows that you know afghanistan will
stand on its own no our intelligence
shows that that kiev will fall within
three days no it's like our intelligence
shows like do you guys have anything
right like is there anything
that is accurate okay first of all
poorly fair so i so on my podcast
president's daily brief we covered this
we talked about this you as a taxpayers
are paying
billions and billions of dollars to the
intelligence community to to act on your
behalf you should be asking questions if
they're falling short so that's fair
i want to pull up this article from army
times
foreboding army psyops recruitment video
shows who's pulling the strings a lot of
people were bringing us up to us saying
it was a really really creepy video i
want to play it is a little long but
i've not seen it
but daniel was just bringing up that the
cia intelligence agencies get so much
wrong and i wonder are they really
getting it wrong or are they just trying
to manipulate you
perhaps you assume that there are a
bunch of bumbling slipping on banana
peels and maybe that's what they want
you to think because what sun tzu had
quotes about this right when you're
strong make your enemy believe you are
weak when you're weak make your enemy
believe you are strong so i've i've
never seen this i don't know if we can
play the full thing but we'll play
ghosts in the machine a controversial
psychological operations advertisement
from the army is there something nice
if your opponent is of choleric temper
seek to irritate him that sounds like
sun tzu
that he may grow arrogant you see my man
sun tzu
all right this is getting pretty creepy
i love that guy
oh clowns
strong start have you ever
who's pulling the strings
[Applause]
wolves hiding nearby
whispering
born from the ashes
is that the emblem of the psychological
operation a world at war
you will find us in the shadows
this is inspiring
at the tip of the spear
a threat rises in the east
russia invades ukraine oh it's pretty
new yeah yeah this is from uh earlier
this month
warfare is evolving who put this out
uh this is a fourth psyop group
i am intrigued and all the world's a
stage yo this is creepy
it's like a movie shakespeare
there is another very important phase of
warfare
it has as its target
not the body
but the mind of the enemy the target of
psychological warfare is against the
enemy's mind
it is words and ideas ammunition used by
cyborg
anything we touch is a weapon
its mission is to influence the thoughts
of the people we can deceive and at the
same time is expected and encouraged
persuade the foreign languages and the
social sciences of changing economics
and sociology
influences have a broad and sympathetic
understanding of all spires of human
experience
gripping
at my skin
the walls of night closing you come in
many forms but the use of this force as
an integral part of combat has now taken
on new form
we are everywhere
that's what they want you to think
[Music]
a feeling in the dark
a message of the stars
[Applause]
ghosts in the machine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what are we psy war what the heck what
is this really it who put that together
army psyops recruitment video that's
what they're saying really yeah
that's interesting
so i can respond to that silliness uh
okay
it's all fake it's all boring oh my god
okay a couple things
i would join right now right now
so i'll tell you i i
i was we get by that is to say in the
intelligence community folks get by with
this kind of stuff everybody thinks that
you know intel people are 10 feet tall
and they're scary and amazing do
anything they want james bond
but i'm telling you that ain't how it is
all right uh i
and and i can share this story with you
um i was looking to work with our group
of folks who go out into the world and
hire knox right those are people that we
would never officially recognize as
intelligence officers
and i asked our knock hiring
officials
what do you look for
and
she said to me we don't look for the f
students obviously or the d students as
it were sort of a b c d f the grades
right d or f students those those kids
don't wouldn't work
but
we can't hire a and b
because they're too good and smart and
they don't want to put up with the
bureaucratic bologna that this place has
so what we have to try to find is like a
good solid c plus student that's me
you sir well i'll put a good word for
you you know since i'm still a fed i am
i i i think it actually is just like the
movies because you know i've i've seen a
lot of burn notice
yeah is that right
okay so they want people that are not so
adherent to authority that they'll get
a's and b's because that's what they're
told to do but they're not so stupid
that they aren't can't follow along it's
that they're willing to join but they're
also willing to betray amb students are
after they have ambition uh but they
want efficiency they want
accomplishments they want it's um
you can go out into the private sector
and earn a ton of money you can go be
successful as your a and b students but
your c student they tend to struggle
more in life so you need somebody that
isn't quite
tip of the spear as that video just said
right so that's what but that shouldn't
be true by the way we should want a
students uh and b students working for
our government because we we want
efficiency we want smarts we want the
best we can get so i i don't buy that
video because of that having been on the
inside um
but i understand why people might think
that that's true the only other quick
caveat i'd add is um
there is one part of me that loves that
because when i was out as an officer i
was meeting with the source
and he
was like why aren't you taking notes i'm
telling you all these great amazing
things well i didn't need to i was able
to capture it and he and he paused he's
like wait a minute
obviously in the movies
uh you have a microphone in your shoe
and i was like
i do
[Laughter]
he was like
so cool
bernie was a cool show man
one of my favorite scenes is when
you guys have seen bernardus right
negative gnome you never seen it it's so
good so it's this former cia contractor
and he's always trying to he's basically
a contractor now for private individuals
trying to help the little guy
and he explains to you how he does
things and why
and it's fascinating so he's like he's
trying to scare a bad guy so he takes a
cell phone tapes it to a box and then
runs the power cable to the wall to make
him think there's a bomb and he was like
that's like the psychological
manipulation stuff so that's what this
show does i love that show that's always
amazing so i what i will tell you that
this contracting thing is actually
really important so we just watch if
this is the army's trying to convince
everybody that they're the 10-foot
monster if you want to talk about power
and the authority to influence and
persuade
that power does not sit within the
military it doesn't sit within the cia
it sits in hollywood it sits in new york
and in dc in terms of those media
operating rooms deciding what what the
editorial line for the day is going to
be what the american people need to
think about it's the people who write
the headlines knowing that 70 80 of
people don't read the story just the
headline that's your power if you want
to shape an agenda if you want to push
people into believing something
that's where you spend your time and
your money it ain't some whiz-bang you
know cia operation that's propaganda
which by the way that was good back in
the 50s and it's not so great now but
anyway
that's where your power is one thing
about the video if we could ask your
your huge followers i feel like i'm
pretty well traveled in this country i
can't think of what city has bright
orange subway cars
so if anything yeah all of your
followers right now if you could be like
oh yeah that's the subway in
i showed it twice and i'm like i know
america pretty well i've i grew up in
new york city i know subways well i
can't think so if i don't i don't went
out there it's not so much the color the
shape of them maybe it wasn't an
american city but i will say i learned
something in my quest to purchase times
square billboards you can actually buy
your an entire train and put whatever
you want on it let's do that yeah i
would just love to think that the army
used like uh the subway of of amsterdam
yeah for a recruitment video
i've been thinking a lot about
using the media like you were saying too
i guess manipulate is the word not you
know sounds like people are saying
someone said japan oh interesting
maryland i saw denmark oh people are
saying whatever yeah they're just saying
whatever
like how do you use the media to please
everyone and i know you can't please
everyone all the time abraham lincoln
quote but like i want to really make the
world better and create new technologies
like running fresh water uh solar
powered heat you know things that will
make us more resilient as a species make
people laugh make people relax like even
the the head of the cia and kim jong-un
want to laugh and relax a little bit but
i've also got to make sure people have
enough food
i don't know if there's people that
actually want to starve the population
so that it grows slower you hear about
bill gates talking about reducing the
growth rate
and i don't know if there are people
that that really want that which seems
crazy but
other than that like you i do you think
we could we could actually use the media
i mean that it's possible well look are
there people in this world who have a
particular agenda for the environmental
issue or the global population or
whatever and then they use their money
to affect that outcome damn straight and
we have foundations in this country all
over the world in fact the united states
have a massive number of private family
foundations that chase after whatever
their own family's goals might be okay
so it's not it wouldn't be a wild
assumption that to hear or or an
argument to hear somebody say this
family or this person really is gets
excited about x issue now they're really
going to change all of our lives just
because they and their big money want to
change it so absolutely there is
precedent for that every day we've got
it um but the the second piece though uh
tell me again it's more of like um i
don't know i'm asking if it's possible i
mean i know you don't have the answer
but you don't think it's possible to fix
this planet bring people together like
all this all of us together yeah and
i'll tell you what it is
real quick
uh
watching the ad there's an advertisement
and it looks to be in german oh
interesting yeah
so so then it was made by the army in
the subway
so we're talking that was the german
army that was putting that out that's a
lot a heck of a lot better that's how
good this psychological warfare is yes
they kept showing the statue of liberty
that's why i was like they're trying to
make you think it's new york
let's be really honest for a second
europe's military is a joke come on in
ukraine do you recall when things were
bubbling up what did germany offer the
ukrainians 5 000 helmets get out of here
their military is absolutely hollowed
out so
anyway that's ridiculous uh but i will
tell you in terms of the media stuff um
you know how can we shape how can we
encourage how do we grow as a people as
a country as a species whatever it might
be
no joke and i'm not saying it because
i'm here it's this
these kinds of shows are where it
happens because what you do is you
encourage people to think to think for
themselves and to think critically
you give them information and you say
hey look here's my bias here's what i
think here's the data that supports my
argument but i'll tell you what your
call you you decide it's up to you
that's what we have to encourage each
other to do that's what i do on my
podcast that's what you all do here on
this show every day that's how we shape
the world we now control the information
we put it out there and people trust us
not just because oh they seem smart but
they but they know that day in and day
out when we talk to them
we say here's the data
you decide here's why it's important to
you but it's your call then people are
less like um what are you trying to do
to me what are you trying to get me to
buy what are you trying to like
manipulate me to think all i'm doing is
saying here's the information here's
what i think but y'all make the call
well that's what's so fascinating about
than the role of of tech right so here's
the data you make the decision i work in
the environmental and energy space and
here's the data that's like so you don't
believe in climate change i'm the
platform from facebook you're not
allowed to be a climate denier on
facebook and you say well i'm not
denying anything i'm just saying here's
a set of facts that need to be discussed
not on our platform because you don't
care and what you just said you
sometimes you strike me that you say
some of the sweetest most like like
humanitarian things and you said i make
the world a better place and give you
know solar heat and clean water you know
where they didn't discuss any of that
sentiment if you paid attention the last
couple days was davos
all those world leaders gathered and
they talked about what we will do oh
there's the photos of them i i had to i
had to know
confirmed germany berlin all right
so did we know this that was the
german army who was like join our psyops
group i don't know why we might be able
to filter on you know who was the last
one that made it during the german army
ad
i'm just saying
no i'm talking about not too small
they bought stock footage
they did they bought footage
uh yeah from getty images but but anyway
your sentiment of how do we find
solutions to the problems that will make
the world a better more peaceful more
healthy more prosperous place at the
individual level you looked at those
yahoos and davos and all they did was
talk about what can we do to make them
obey or how do we cut countries off the
global monetary and banking system if
they won't vaccinate their people and
everyone claps and john kerry how do we
punish people that will not accept
climate change everyone collapse that
whole thing should have been we should
have built the wall around davos and
forced them to live there and given them
some primitive weapons and and hunger
games we gotta we gotta hit super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button and subscribe to
the channel share the show if you really
do like it head over to timcast.com
become a member uh no member segments
today but we do that monday through
thursday at 11 p.m
uh we're gonna read some super chats i'm
gonna start with uh one that's just it's
closer to the end and then we'll go back
to the beginning but uh catman says tim
i listen on spotify normally you should
put something to mark the ads around the
27 minute mark talking about death
penalty your ad read started with i'd
like to know where my meat comes from oh
my gosh that's amazing
great well you know that's how it works
i cannot control that i'm sorry that's
great all right spiro fluoropolis says
sources say dot online tim's word cue
idea is in beta mode if anybody at
timcast wants access to try it please
reach me i've emailed spin the ufo
before or tell me who and how to contact
to give access i don't know
oh i'll explain to you do you want to
check the spin the ufo for spiro
floropolis so um
i've been having this thing you know
ranting about wikipedia how we should
sue them
you can't there's wikipedia can create a
defamatory article but because it's
community generated no one can be sued
you can't sue wikipedia because they're
protected by section 230 you can't sue
the individual editor because they don't
make a complete statement
if an editor writes daniel
daniel turner
raises sheep
or lamb that's that's that's true right
okay you can't sue that person what if
someone then goes in and changes raises
to you know what he's going to say oh
boy
brutalizes yes
that's definitely not true they never
said you did
they added one word you can't sue
someone for saying one word uh
defamation you can argue it is
because of the place they put it in but
they can be like i just put in a single
word i didn't i didn't do anything i
mean so who do you sue yeah i think the
closest argument you can get to is
well because of all the other words that
were there you're the one who completed
the statement by changing the word
technically that person but they never
actually said anything so it's arguable
and i've talked to lawyers about this
they're like i don't know
you can't you can't sue anybody i guess
so the idea for this program is
we will create an article
we'll title it nancy pelosi
and then as soon as you load the page
you are placed in a queue
based on when you loaded it first second
and third so if you're the first person
in it'll say sources say blank you get
to write one word
the next person who loaded the website
can put the second word
and as the article gets bigger you'll
get more and more time to figure out
your work because you've got to read it
but then
every individual has only written one
word
who are you going to assume
so you'll have this really long article
making this really ridiculous statement
with no one who can be suited
to try and sue the person that owns the
website then wikipedia will get sued
exactly you can't it's a section two we
didn't write it's users yeah i love that
it's it's their rules so play them yeah
brilliant and what we'll do too is we'll
make it so that when you add the word it
doesn't actually put the word in the
article until the article's done
because then no one wrote the article ah
love it they might be able to argue that
like well there were 700 words already
there and you put that word in there so
i completed a statement it's like okay
well we won't then you'll you'll you'll
read it you'll add your word and then
once it's done it'll go connect them all
it's like mad libs but better yeah yeah
all right let's read some more
ashton de rojas says can you let people
know schumer is planning a senate vote
on two gun control bills day after
memorial day and to call your state reps
and senators to oppose these bills
better yet call your state reps and
senators and demand they repeal
the nfa yes and abolish the atf i
suppose you know and uh why don't we get
some republicans who actually want to
repeal some of these these gun laws
starbuck all that all that keeps
happening is republicans are like we'll
compromise with you democrats and ban
some stuff and then democrats just keep
saying ban more they're just raking in
the money man
these congress people that should have
been out after four years maybe eight
years
all right beckmeister says new york
shooters discord username
dis discord id about me you can't begin
to imagine how we get them to do the
things they do
i mean but is that that could be anybody
this could be a random crazy person
who's trying to egg on people you know
what i mean yeah
eden hiddick tim you are right that meds
can cause these mass shootings i say
this as someone who was almost driven by
medication induced insanity into doing
one i'm willing to get into contact if
you want to know more wow that's crazy
yeah people go crazy yeah really rob
short says press f to abolish this fed
oh no they're talking about you yeah
i got it how about this hold on i
thought they're done with the fence
smash the like button to end the fence
we're going to end the fed let's see
what we got oh no
hold on 18. ah boom at least i'm old
enough to vote i'm just saying at the
end of the night you guys have to turn
everything upside down and make sure
there are no bugs on you know yeah all
your little knickknacks
all right
uh phalanx says tim you keep talking
about 3d printed guns but why not the
looty it's also my birthday so i have
some of my money oh thank you what's the
lootie how do you spell l-u-t-y
i don't know i am unfamiliar not sure
that's everyone's everyone's hero was
playing when rome was burning he was
playing the lieutenant i heard that that
was actually not true but i'd like to go
into that deeper the ludi submachine gun
oh oh my everybody is putting f in chat
but hold on i said that if you want to
uh smash the like button
and
you guys can't listen close
well maybe they're just trying to
abolish the fed oh i see
mark h says tom mcdonald would be an
awesome future guest you guys rock he
would yeah he would tom you are always
welcome to come on the show you know
what i would love to do too is do a
music collaboration with him because we
have one song
that's kind of punk rock i can't
get a ver i can't write a verse to i
just don't know tom would be great and
so i was like it's faster so maybe what
it needs is rap so it can convey the
story in a meaningful way so i reached
out to him but he's a busy guy there's
some other people i have in mind we'll
see if we can get done
got a lot of music stuff in the world
awesome man yo it's just everybody is so
busy there's there's the talent pool is
is talented people are busy it's all
bought up and it's hard yeah we're
trying to find we're we're talking to
some big
industry music people but they're like
yo everybody is is swamped
where where's everybody at you know
speaking of music i loved your chicken
city theme song yes oh yeah oh yeah is
that live now it's the deck well i saw
the making of and i just thought it was
so endearing i haven't heard the
relationship it's just four chords i i
wrote it in 10 seconds that's great
though put you in a good mood oh yeah
music roberto is the sheriff of chicken
city and roberto junior is his deputy
but roberto's uh uh at the boys town now
oh he's he's in freedom good for him so
with his sons
yeah so uh he was a he's aggressive
roberto junior is much much nicer to the
girls see brahma
roberto jr is rhode island red and
easter egger of some sort some kind of
mix but he looks just like a rhode
island red i think i saw him outside
he's beautiful yeah yeah so roberto was
getting really aggressive he ju he jump
kicked me one day yeah he was getting
and we can't have him banging his
daughters no
yeah so he already did and he had a
bunch of granddaughter daughters
illegitimate grandchildren that's the
limit yeah you know for line breeding i
guess yeah we're not supposed to
you can do it once i guess for certain
traits yeah so now he's got a few
granddaughter daughters
and his uh and and these chickens are
there are there they they are their own
ants i think is that what it is oh
that's right you're gonna want to change
that yeah bloodline we did yeah well so
roberto junior is his son but we have uh
uh uh two brahma roosters now
that roberto's son roberto sons with our
brahma sarah so i think we're gonna do
is we're gonna take all the boys out
because we have a silky who's been
yelling
love them and then the silky breeds with
everybody and makes uh sentences lucky
silky silkies are great do roosters
generally have a different call like a
or what do you call that a
cock-a-doodle-doo what is that bro
they do based upon what when we would
notice uh you when you live with them
and you have them on the farm and you
know as well you know what they're
saying when there was a fox nearby it
was a different sound when it was like
run and take cover he would make some
sound uh our our rudest name was uh was
cletus
and uh and all the hens would run into
the house like it was like what heads up
here comes the fox they all have
different sounds it's very cool adrian
curry in chat says house lannister hens
is correct
that is what they are that's very good
oh man that's very good all right let's
read some more dd says the state is a
joke they do not care about you well of
course they don't duh
yeah most of these politicians are like
i just want to say the bare minimum that
i have to to get reelected
that's about it there's like 10
politicians who are actually trying
stuff
all right minion 715 says tim check out
new york response with bill s9407 making
the purchase or possession of all types
of body armor a felony if it is passed
that's no good
man
why how do you how do you legally define
body armor then so you know what they
were doing in thailand is they would buy
um x-ray sheets
and they would they would uh stagger
them
inside vest as plates nice and i don't
know if that actually worked but they
they said it did you take a bit a whole
bunch of the x-ray film
and it creates some kind of you know oh
interesting yeah i have to ask how do
you justify banning a defensive not even
a weapon a defensive thing what case do
you make that says oh you shouldn't be
able to actually literally protect your
vital organs from a possible attack
which we know are happening by the way i
don't get it i'll get it
welder1 says tim you need to buy
billboards near establishment media that
reads if you want real news news go to
timcast.com nice we we we did have some
i don't know if they went up they might
be in chicago
and it's a quote from michael malus that
says um what is it the quote was
something like the corporate press gives
you the narrative timcast.com or tim
cass gives you the news i think that's
on some of the billboards so i did see
that we have the one in times square but
that was more of like a statement like
we're here get used to it
and uh we bought a bunch in chicago
because that was actually like
the biggest regional demographic for the
show is chicago so
i was like we'll put them in chicago
because apparently people in chicago
like the show and we'll see how that
works out we'll see if it works out but
either way we we've done zero marketing
until this point and so uh you know
we'll see what happens
and it's all thanks to all of you as
members we're going to keep growing i
think we need to stop
a lot of people all of these all of
these channels all of these independent
creators need to stop looking at the
establishment mainstream media as if
they are some big monolith and start
recognizing that we've we've you know we
we've beached the shore we are storming
yeah we've reached the walls we are we
are running across the beaches of
normandy figuratively
and uh they're firing all of these
smears and hit pieces desperate to stop
us
but all we got to do is as we get big
enough is just start taking over those
spaces
so uh you know i don't know super bowl
ads or something yeah and you'll realize
when you start doing it too that the
amount of cover you run as an
independent journalist or an independent
creator is so much more than a guy on a
beach head storming against machine guns
one guy doesn't provide a lot of cover
for everyone else but when you're a loud
voice in the media man is that a
distraction for the people that aren't
comfortable with it what's funny is the
hubris of the mainstream folks
in their position like you know anderson
cooper there are more people watching
bobby flay make a frittata than her
watching him but if he would tell you
he's the most important voice in i think
people have forty thousand fifty
thousand people watching them a night so
it's kind of funny to see that they
still think they're these powerful
voices and they're really we shouldn't
give them any any props because they're
they're kind of
uh obsolete
all right junkie pox says cops are now
watered down the pokemandate made many
good ones leave the defund programs and
protests made the good ones leave
effective cops also typically have past
military training and there are few
remaining
this was the point i was trying to make
on twitter which was probably not well
framed but
when you create a culture around the
defund movement
and you demonize cops and you riot the
good cops leave and then you get there
there's there's two kinds of cops
there's the cop who's like i am doing
this job not because of the rewards i'm
doing because i must i must be the
person to run in to save those lives and
then you get other cops who are like i
don't know man i just need a job
and what we have now are the i don't
know man i just need a job
i'm not gonna run in there and get shot
at you nuts i'm just here for the
paycheck
because the good cops don't want to be
there anymore
that's sad man
all right drake tilson says i'm an ffl
many ffls offer payment plans through
their credit card processing companies
so they can close sales with people who
otherwise don't have the cash or credit
to pay for the firearm
interesting i mean financing is
financing you know
flinch sun says in reference to your
earlier segment the reason that feds are
referred to as glowies
is from terry a davis and his less than
charitable term he uses for the cia and
how they glow in the dark
oh yeah that sounds right yup checks out
all right
arch
archmagos aaron carbo says i would
charge in to save any child i could from
such a fate i don't think i could stop
myself from berserking on in there to
stop him or die trying that's what i'm
saying i don't know if i would have any
logical thought at all i might just be
like yeah kick the door in i am but the
but the the cbp guy exactly that he
grabbed the gun and he went for it some
people are just like run in yeah save
these kids i don't even have kids and i
was imagining how i would feel in that
situation and it was making my blood
pressure rise i can understand if
someone was like you were unarmed and
there was someone with a weapon and
you'd like what do i do but these were
cops with guns that's why i'm saying
like i don't i'd probably just
do it poorly but freak out i'd probably
freak out i don't know what to say man
i mean maybe maybe it's all uh well and
good like we like to believe we would be
better at it than they would but i gotta
tell you man i've run into danger for
stupider reasons
it's i just it leaves me speechless
really
speechless available on amazon
michael knowles thank you
oh my gosh ridiculous never dies
genius marketing
he's got us
okay let's try and grab some more super
chats
david c cronk senior says i find it very
disconcerting that we as a society put
our money into a more secure place than
we put our children we deserve what we
get
well you know
you get what you deserve it doesn't you
know it that's used in a bad way in a
lot of
senses you get what you deserve but it's
not always a bad thing it's like you you
know the story of the the king who said
he wanted uh
who was it his blacksmith to make him
something that would make him happy when
he was sad and sad when he was happy i'm
probably ruining the story or whatever
you ever hear this one yeah he's like i
challenge you to produce an item that
would make me sad when i'm happy and
happy when i'm sad
and so he made a ring or something that
engraved and it said this too shall pass
that's a great line yeah so like it's
from ecclesia you know when you say you
get what you deserve it's a good thing
you work really hard you'll get what you
deserve yeah you do bad things you will
get what you deserve
raymond g stanley jr says tim make a
short film about him praise strength
we could we could do something some
people do instead do an animation or
something
about the uh here we go james green
shade says they did make a movie about
that guy it's called die hard
that's right you see those were the
heroes we had like i had when i was a
kid yeah the dude who used to take the
gun to his back and he's got his hands
up in there crawling through the vents
yeah yep broken glass there's no shoes
on so but at what point though did they
are they the good guys and then they
become the fed like what's the crossover
crossover yeah
and by the way can we just shut the
lights off and you can confirm
yeah i don't know you did the right
thing no i i don't uh i mean i think
it's all just about generalities
uh generalizations like there are bad
feds like the ones who go to the garage
pole rope but the ones who don't go and
deal with political corruption
i think for the most part everybody uh
i've talked to some active feds who are
total maga
and what i've told is that it's not as
cut and dry as people think a lot of
people think that the entirety of like
the fbi is all trump derangement
syndrome and it's like no it's the same
as the world it's the same as the
country a bunch of them are especially
because they're living in dc so you see
a lot of them
but then there's a bunch of you know
there's manga ones and then there's like
middle of the road guys
and the problem is
as you see in the real world
conservatives and centrists rarely speak
up and so the trump derangement ones are
doing what they want the other guys are
like i don't know man you know i
shouldn't say anything i could lose my
job i got kids and that's the reality
yeah that's the problem
bad people do bad things and if you know
all that is required for evil to triumph
is that good men do nothing correct good
persons
good people can do bad things if they're
in bad systems
yes it's true very very true history
shows that true
that's sad man
oh vice versa bad people can do good
things in good systems
raymond g stanley jr says quote ian you
are right sounds like a freudian slip so
weird but you said it very intense
it was true
julio velalta the third says just saw a
tim cast irl billboard off interstate by
midway airport also seen in that area
regular gas at 5.53 a gallon
so when i was buying the billboards in
chicago i was like at least one of them
has to be off interstate 55 at central
avenue because that's where i grew up
the rest can be in strategic places but
that one that one's for my friends did
you get it yeah yeah apparently it's up
i don't know it's going to go up right
away awesome yeah so uh
years ago we've done we've done a bunch
of different polls and we also have
analytic data and chicago is always the
biggest not by much
but i think it makes sense considering
i'm from chicago so people there
probably have similar opinions we grew
up in the same place
so i was like all right well you know if
we're going to buy ads and actually buy
ads we'll do it in chicago it's a big
city and the people there have similar
views not it's a big liberal city for
sure but if you if you don't like
democrats and you're not a conservative
in chicago you're basically like me you
know
if you guys see billboards get a nice
high-res shot of it and tweet it at me
tag me in it and i'll see if we can
circulate it on the show yes maybe get
the address of where it is the location
josh oh my gosh says tim if the
government subsidizes guns using tax
money it may turn out like the
university is raising prices to get more
money no thanks that is a good point so
i was only half joking i was making a
point about how republicans never
actually fight for things the way
democrats do democrats are like we
demand you pay for our health care and
then health care goes crazy and then i'm
like okay then we depend demand you pay
for our guns yeah how about here's a
compromise i will say yes universal
health care if you say yes to universal
guns and it works out too because with
all the guns everywhere you're worried
don't worry hospital's covered for you
yeah
don't you know you don't these people
don't realize that you don't just get
free stuff because you want it it means
we get free stuff too that's fair yeah
i also think it's funny that the student
debt forgiveness people are like
13 of the population and they want all
of the poor people to subsidize their
their degrees do you see that there were
a study done by the the fed the the
other fed oh the fed yes the other ones
the bankers yeah the one we want to end
yeah yeah
they surveyed student uh loan uh folks
and 70 of them could as this moment
continue their payments in other words
70 percent of folks who have student
loans absolutely need no assistance
interesting that this whole conversation
around the loan forgiveness not
necessarily everybody needs it yeah but
they're all getting 10 000.
yeah yeah ten thousand bonkers
i mean that's that's nuts man okay all
right let's see second fleet actual says
tim if they aren't old enough to be
armed they aren't old enough to vote
force them to choose one or the other
there you go
yeah i think they would give them the
guns
raise the age of everything they'd be
like okay let's get 16 year olds to vote
there was a a bunch of students
protested gun violence and they were
like just because we're students doesn't
mean we aren't allowed you know we
aren't they're like we're you know just
because we're students not all the
protests and i'm like no your lack of
experience and knowledge on these issues
is why you shouldn't protest but i don't
really mean you shouldn't protest i'm
just saying like
i don't think you as a gun control
person regardless of age has done any
research on this no that's it i don't
care how old you are you can be 14 and
if you're like i have not googled this
but i'm going to protest on that you
maybe maybe you should yeah and unless
i'm a 16 year old set policy it was that
swedish chick and they basically led
europe into war right so so let's not
have 16 year olds make any more policy
decisions
i would like to translate for greta
tunberg when she was like we don't want
to wait till 2030 or 2022. she was
actually saying i want to kill 60
million people today
sounds familiar and you think i'm joking
but if you she said she wanted to shut
down all fossil fuels today i'm like
yeah overnight 60 million people around
the world die yeah they've also figured
out how to upscale colon to graphene i
don't know if you've been following that
at all but they hit with lasers and they
can turn into much cleaner burn fields
well you see now go to tune berg trying
to take away ian's graph
and your buddy in chicago should know
that a 550 is bad wait till august oh
it's going to get much much worse are
you waiting wait till making your own
fuel wait till the harvest wait till the
harvest i'm trying no no fertilizer i
know
this fall harvest is going to be a shock
to the system we're still eating last
year's crops you know most of the wheat
and we've some winter wheat was
harvested recently but very little we're
still eating last year's wheat we're
actually growing wheat as well you have
to yeah they're weeds volunteers we
ignored them for a long time and then we
realized it was wheat now look at us
leave it i guess
i was like i guess we'll make bread yeah
we got a whole bunch growing and i was
like what is this strange plant growing
oh now how are you going to harvest it
by the way do you have the side what do
you got to cut it you got to get a
sausage right katana
no i won't use that i'll use one of my
other katanas dude let's get a
grindstone
to sharpen them yeah no no two i'll
grind the wheat once we get it out oh
yeah
no no no no we're gonna get a donkey
yeah the donkey walks in the circle and
a millstone absolutely that would be
great
old school oh it's a millstone the
grindstone is for the blade i feel like
that could be another youtube channel
for you just the donkey going around and
starting oh yeah
super like cathartic drop a carrot every
yeah 500 bucks and supercharged i would
watch that like time to follow
yes
we have a 60 camera right now we're
talking we have the chicken parties at
chickencitylive.com so you can give five
bucks and then treats come down and then
once a hundred dollars hits a chicken
party happens and so when we were
launching pop culture crisis live i said
we need to do the same thing you know
like we need to have it so that when
people super chat something happens and
then when you reach a number something
happens so now
during pop culture crisis
the host and you know we'll be talking
and if you super chat a money gun shoots
20s into the air
and then once a hundred dollars is
reached a crisis party happens where
police lights go off and then money
starts flying at people and then one
flew into each other it's a bit
distracting it is a little hit
one fell on the coffee but it's funny
all right let's see
odysseus horse says tim if you're
serious about the absolute nature of 2a
you should get brandon herrera the ak
guy ought to tell you about the atf form
to register your nuclear device i'd love
to hear it i have tried so many times to
get that man he is busy as all get out
someday brandon herrera is his name yeah
matthew fetig says hey tim love all your
work anyway the irl can do a poll of the
day and then talk about it a little on
the show to help the show feel even more
engaging that's a good idea
we could do something in the in the um
community section on the on the page
like maybe uh maybe in the morning
well or maybe maybe just before maybe a
couple hours before the show and the
news instead of like you know hear like
some big stories we'll see what people
are interested in or you know we'll ask
questions then we can pull it up on the
show that would be fun actually it's a
good idea um matthew you get you get no
royalties it's ours you give us the idea
we own it
yeah you forfeit all rights no we'll see
we'll see what about my donkey idea can
i get in them on that
let's do that
i'll give you back the hundred dollars
[Laughter]
that proves you're not affected got it
yeah so like to earn redemption you gave
me a hundred bucks i'll give it back
yeah there you go good donkey idea
matt reese says the left are saying
mental health isn't an issue while you
see a clear trend to normalize mental
illness as if madness should be the new
baseline
yeah well unfortunately this is the hill
i'm on right now is the pharmaceutical
industry is the root problem of this
because just too much of a coincidence
not to be fritter says disabled guy here
i walk with a cane love it when my
friends yell hurry up dude i only have
two speeds if you don't like this one
you sure as hell won't like the other
i love that guy that's great
food for life global says our charity is
ffl.org and our mission is to unite the
world through the sharing of pure food
we serve over one million vegan meals a
day oh that's cool ffl too i thought it
would be a gun thing yeah it's food for
life wait that's three f's that's f f f
l wait wait that's f that's f g four
food for f in life oh i'm an idiot oh
tim can't count i can't count where is
that food for life wwjd
fflg that's that that's what it was
i pulled another biden what what's going
on you gotta get sleepy yeah you gotta
take a take a meditation break you're
gonna love the fresh air yeah if i pull
more bidens like this i don't know if i
keep doing the show forest bathing but i
do like the fact that whenever i scroll
up i can say i pulled a biden yeah
because it makes it funny
and then you have to whisper something
really creepy and angry i'm your
commander-in-chief
that was so creepy today it gave me like
a goosebumps like oh he did that we'll
grab we'll grab two more here
uh let's see uh phalanx says the ludi is
a nine millimeter smg
uh that is built entirely from things
you find at the hardware store british
anti-gun control guy phil ludi wrote a
book showing how to do it oh wow you
can't ban the knowledge that's crazy
nice you cannot no nacho nabo says shout
out to riley highland the chicken cams
will be forever known as tim tim cest
whoa
is that because roberto and his
daughters oh
that makes sense
don't put your name with that you didn't
do anything wrong yeah i didn't join
nature he did
and you know what was funny is we put
dorothy in sex jail yeah because he was
going at her too much and hurt her back
yeah she was the she was the victim of
she was the she was the face she was the
punished she was the favorite and so we
had to separate her and people got mad
they were like why shouldn't you put
roberto in there and that's like well
but he's the rooster and he like
keeps the girls in in check and like
guards them and if we separate him he
might come back out and fight with his
son so we can't but then eventually we
decided it's time to send roberto off to
the uh the mine over at freedom stand
with the boys
and uh uh so we put him in sexual i'm
sure she appreciated a little break also
she didn't feel like her lady oh she's
not no it's been a couple of months and
she's not throwing the feathers back she
needs some reiki
yeah you know and and for some reason
she is the favorite even for roberto jr
now it's r it's crazy that chicken
hormones i don't i don't know anything
about chicken attractiveness but she
must be a supermodel lady the bard rock
yeah yeah yeah she's you know it's
really funny we have two bard rock they
look like zebras they're like you know
white and black and vanessa has always
got a furled brow and that's how you
tell them apart you see vanessa and
she's always looking angry at you like
this with her eyes
and dorothy's eyes are always up like oh
she's very cute so you instantly just
know who's who
they're very friendly they're both real
friendly to humans too that might have
something to do with them being the
favorites of the roosters
adrian curry says eat roberto he will
always be a part of you
[Laughter]
justice has been served
[Music]
uh i don't i i don't think we'll eat any
of the original cast which includes
roberto but all the rest of them they
don't have names or fair games and we
can't name the 50 of them that we have
so we named one of the brahmas
the son of sarah isaac because in the
bible sarah's son is isaac so he's safe
and sarah is safe and then she has
another son and daughter i guess they'll
be safe i like the bible trend that's
cool well i just i don't know it's just
an idea someone came up with i guess so
uh you know we'll see how chicken city
goes but also guys check out pop culture
crisis on youtube live monday through
friday at 3 p.m we're going to be doing
some ads for them as well as the show
starts kicking up and getting to full
speed and uh it's going really good i
mean lydia and ian have been on the show
so fun this week actually that was great
yeah so uh smash the like button if you
haven't already subscribe to the channel
share the show is the most powerful
thing you can do you know we started
buying uh doing this marketing thing
recently but everything for this show
has been organic growth which is just
totally nuts and i talked to some
marketing people who couldn't believe it
they were like no way not just yeah just
people were sharing it i guess they like
it yeah so that really is the most
powerful thing but now we'll do
traditional marketing and we're going to
take over that's what we're going to do
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
you can follow me personally at tim cast
brian you want to shout anything out i'm
just so pleased to be here can't wait to
come back if you have me even though if
i glow
but uh please uh the president's daily
brief love it if you all listen to that
and uh i'm on twitter brian dean wright
always great to be here daniel turner
daniel turner
powerthefuturepowerthefuture.com
and also always a shout out to bristol
farmvirginia on instagram uh our
fantastic sheep farm i sent you i sent
you a picture of the sheep but i don't
know if you can pull it up in time i
can't pull it up in time but i am gonna
put that link in your in our uh bio so
your socials will happen my sheep are
just they're adorable they're the most
beautiful sheep in the world swiss valet
they're just beautiful so anyway did you
shave them yet uh
the scottish blackface will get sheared
uh next week are they gonna record it
they're getting really hot you guys want
to come record it you can it's kind of
funny i like the idea they'll be so
happy because they're hot right now oh
they're so hot they have so much wool
but uh yeah bristol farm virginia on
instagram and great to be here thanks
for having me have a great weekend i
used to think it was unethical to shore
and shave sheep just because the way
they scream and struggle but i saw a
sheep with so much wool it couldn't move
yeah so you kind of got a nose
you see how they vaccinate the baby
sheep they have them sitting in that
conveyor belt thing with their feet up
and it just like pulls them forward and
they don't move and they just gives them
the shot and then it drops them and they
walk away that's great i love it daniel
always great oh really great to see you
man brian really good to see you dude
and we did joke about the whole cia that
you worked with uh the fed and
everything but that's like thank you so
much for doing that and and
the work you've done
and for coming and talking about it
anytime can't wait to see you again man
this is great stuff i followed you on
twitter lydia i love you tim always a
pleasure my man all right i wanted to
leave you guys with this quick thought i
was just talking to chris carr who's one
of our editors over at timcast.com and i
said chris i would really like to know
how many of the cops who just stood in
the hallway with all those kids were
dying had their own kids i was like i'm
willing to bet that not a lot of them
have their own children and i was like
this is how a culture dies we're not
willing to defend the people who need
our defense the most because our family
line ends with us and if we're to die
that's it so anyway that's not exactly a
bright note to leave you with but i also
want to say you guys can follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sourpatchlits
as well as southpatchlets.me
thanks for hanging out everybody check
out pop culture crisis on youtube and
subscribe to it and check out
chickencitylive.com
we have the cast castle vlog up every
day and we'll be back with the show we
are working on memorial day it's gonna
be a lot of fun thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all then bye guys
you